welcome everybody we're back for another
i'm not gm speed chess championship
match i'm grand master robert hess
alongside me
is my good friend grandmaster mon
hamilton amman
we have a great match up ahead don't we
yeah this is gonna be an exciting one
robert two people that i think
potentially the community on twitch here
are not as familiar with
but for chess players and professionals
alike or anyone following
the over-the-board classical chess scene
these names should not be too unfamiliar
especially
one of the names who uh in the last
edition of this exact event robert
made it quite far and almost took down
the whole thing
yeah she's very used to this format and
remind everybody of what that is
it is a single elimination bracket and
there are three separate time controls
the
longest time control is five minutes
plus a one second increment
it's followed by three minutes plus one
second increment and finally we get
25 minutes of bullet chest at one plus
one and
of course you advance to the next round
where the prize money increases and
elena cash and skaia as a mom was just
alluding to she made it to the final
last year where she was defeated by john
bartholomew who is not taking part this
year which
may clear the path for her way to a
championship run but of course
she must get through this very tough
challenge in round one she is the 14th
seed
taking on number three lars oscar hogg
so amman
in this matchup here between two very
strong competitors
who do you give the favorite do you have
the seed favorite or the
repeating player in elena kashanskaya
well the the interesting thing about
this matchup and uh
i just want to point out that i feel
like alina is consistently getting
undersold in these tournaments um if you
think back to the i'm not a gm
last uh last edition uh i think she was
jeez i want to say almost like the the
last uh the last seat in terms of
favorite to win and she made it all the
way to the finals
and gave an insane performance by the
way so
just i think it's someone not to bet
against i think elena has proven herself
in all formats people were even saying
oh maybe she'll be impressive in the
blitz
in the longer time controls but there's
no way she holds her own bullet
absolutely incorrect so if i've learned
one thing it's
not to bet against selena for no
apparent reason so
be very careful there she's incredibly
incredibly talented
and the bullet portion i was especially
impressed with by her so
um lars i know a little bit uh less
about
in terms of online play but robert you
and i were discussing some of the
ratings that he's boasting online right
now and they sort of speak for
themselves
yeah he's 2800 in bullet and you're just
referring to the fact that hey alina she
thought was thought to be the underdog
in the bullet
but that one second increment can make a
world of difference and we are off
lars gets the white peas in the first
game and we have my absolute favorite
opening
yours too aman the french wow what a
what a place to start robert it's it's
like they know
it's like they know wow
and alina does usually come quite well
prepared
and in this case we have the winner
where you see the situation the bishop
on b4 pins the knight on c3
and now lara says here take my knight i
get the bishop pair
and there will be open space to work
with but how about those double pawns of
mine you have a lot of experience
playing the french
yeah i was actually wondering whether we
would see c5 because it's
i guess the more topical line right now
more of a main line but the the 97 move
order does give you the option to play
b6 here
and go for bishop a6 which i thought was
her intention it's often why black
inserts knight e7 first but no we're
going back to c5
and maybe uh some of the chat would be a
little more familiar with some of those
lines where
the white queen gets down there and ends
up taking all the king side pawns
in exchange for black ruining all the
queenside pawns over here so
we haven't quite got that instead it's
the h-pawn robert just
just throwing itself up the board these
guys are neglecting beast development
yeah and i like what alina did as a
response because if
white were able to push that pawn to h6
then the dark squares become very
vulnerable around the black king side
and guess what only white has the dark
sword bishop so instead
alina she played h6 and now after bishop
b5 checked bishop d7
look at this move a6 it's clear alina
wants to use the man's idea
bishop to b5 try to trade those bishops
but not so fast when your opponent g7 is
under attack
yeah and this move bishop b5 it might
not look like much by white but if you
play bishop d3 right away
bishop a6 would follow so bishop b5 you
want to lure the bishop
to the d7 square and then go back and
say look well now you don't have bishop
a6 and you have to waste the move quote
unquote ways to move with a6
in order to complete that idea
completely agreed and when you play move
like a6 you look at the b6 square next
to it
it becomes a little more vulnerable
because a pollen's best friend is
another pawn so black very likely after
c4
will try to advance some pawns on the
queen side but
we'll see if that's enough for alina to
actually
kind of unleash her pieces because right
now look at that bishop on d7 in
particular
that is a french bishop if i've ever
seen one stuck behind the wall of ponds
yeah that's a that's a tough wall to be
behind but
um it is par for the course in these
kind of positions
i have to say like i always look at
these positions and think
white has is doing so well because you
know this g pawn is going to get up
there at some point queen f4 g4
but black sometimes puts this bishop i
was going to say puts this bishop on a4
and it looks like a funny move but hits
that pawn on c2
stops white from playing a4 which you
know would be a dream to get that bishop
on
a3 on that long diagonal and you know
slowly but surely b5 a5 b4
might happen in the future and i'm
currently wondering he was rook
a2 and i think that may have been a bit
too defensive i'm looking at knight h4
and i'm trying to dislodge this knight
from f5 to win the g7 pawn but now it's
a move too slow
because if you're playing knight h4 i
have knight c6 to e7
so i can reinforce the 995 that's
exactly what alina does i think that she
has a pretty dream position
with the superior pawn structure and now
the stable knight on f5
absolutely and now if you if you
exchange of course the other knight
is going to appear there and if you ever
move the queen and play g4 and kick the
knight out
keep in mind that there's no way
there'll still be an attack on g7 so
alina has sort of stabilized this king
probably either gonna walk to the
queenside or even long castle
but both look pretty safe behind this
impressive uh
wall of pawns here and i think going
forward
who has the advantage it's probably
about level i see the evaluation bar on
screen says
well zeros which that doesn't mean
anything this isn't a dead draw there's
plenty of life left
but it'll be dictated by who controls
the pawn breaks and we've been talking
about b5
a5 maybe a b4 break for black on the
queen side perhaps white will move that
queen
like we just have seen in g4 f4 maybe f
or g5 it's a very
complex position full of rich ideas and
it's closed for now but don't be
surprised when this whole board opens up
definitely yeah we're gonna see the
pawns move up the board remember white
has the bishop pair whenever you have
the bishops you gotta try to open things
up so whether it's g4
g5 whether it's g4 f4 f5
uh something has to give here and um and
lars oscar has
a rook tied down on the queen side but
otherwise his prospects on the king side
look pretty good here yeah and i like
your plan though mon
castle queen side because black can also
play on the king side with her pawn she
can strike back with the time the f6 or
g6
when the moment feels right but she
instead goes queen b5 and is queen bee
one
a big threat here hitting the rook in
the bishop i absolutely think so
queen b1 is it's a hilarious move
getting behind enemy lines
um even if you played queen b1 and rook
b2 happen you can even go to a1 and
just sort of hang out there for the
moment which would be nuts but
castles by white and i was wondering
what was going to happen after rook b2
like is she going to go queen a5 then
she might but i i feel like you're kind
of toned there suggested you don't like
the queen sitting on a5 it's far away
from the rest of the board
so i wonder if she thought she could
play queen to b1
and she would have been able to had that
pawn did on a7
rather than on a6 because the queen
needs to stay in touch with the pawn on
b6 and thus couldn't use your idea of
queen b1 queen a1 without dropping that
pawn
yeah and now that that the i guess the
idea queen b5 didn't work out for black
uh what i see is that that's just been a
massive waste of time
and white's got castle kicked the queen
out with the rook
got an f5 in f6 is the next idea if it
can happen
and i think lars has opened up what
could be a pretty significant advantage
here
unless alina reacts pretty aggressively
right now because the move f6 robert i
feel like white gets that in
it's you may as well resign well you say
if white gets that in i agree with you
then black is just strategically
so why shouldn't black play f6 there it
is
because white has castle kingside even
if it costs you a pawn
breaking open the king's side was a king
on g1 and
that king could be susceptible to a
counter attack i like this move f6 a lot
as amman was highlighting if white
played it there's this destruction down
the f-file
instead the board can blow open at any
moment and we'll see to whose advantage
it is bishops tend to thrive
with an open board right but the king is
over there so that's the trade-off
yeah and and keep in mind that when
things start to open up
on the king side potentially alina is
going to be the one with more firepower
over there
because this rook is tethered to the c2
pawn
and isn't doing anything on the b file
so it's basically just
kind of stuck on the queen side now you
could say the bishop is stuck as well
but from black's perspective you're kind
of putting three points over there
and tying down five points if you think
of it mathematically so
that could be something good for for
lena as things open up but
i'm always concerned about what the
bishops can do in an open position
completely with you there and i will add
that i think for many people in our
audience
rook f1 to b1 would make sense because
you're doubling rooks and
hitting the b6 pawn but note that black
has a very easy response in b6 to b5
putting the pawn on the square defended
by another pawn and that bishop and the
queen
so i'm just saying you attacked me i
simply defended
now your rooks are useless over there so
the rook on b2 as amman was highlighting
that doesn't want to be there would much
prefer to be on f2
over on the king side but that journey
would drop the c2 pawn so not happening
anytime soon
right queen d7 played here and
i mean uh i think that uh lars could
sort of approach this
position a bit so it's not it's not like
anybody has to
take uh the pawns in the current
position there's a lot of tension
and what what i see it at some of the
lower levels robert is as soon as
there's tension
it's gone so it's there for a move and
as soon as you can take something it's
so tempting
to just relieve that tension and make
things easier to calculate
but oftentimes keeping the tension is is
how you build things up so
right now we can see neither player
willing to bite because if white takes
on e6
black is happy to take back with the
queen and all of a sudden
the queen is you know pinning that jeep
on putting pressure on e5 more
centralized
so neither player is looking to give any
ground here no
indeed not and it's a really good lesson
in when you should capture when you
should leave the tension as it is and
look at this
now that the rook went to f8 the pawn on
f6 was captured
but i'm still looking at this and it was
smart of lars to put the king on h1 but
shouldn't black just now play f5 and
continue
breaking open more lines in front of the
white king this rook on d2 is the
biggest problem on the board because
all of black's pieces can come to the
king side for the attack
and this rook on b2 is a bystander on
the queen side and end games will also
be problematic for white
because of this double pawns on c3 and
z2
yeah love this move though uh queen g3
sort of inviting the move f4
and f4 closes off that diagonal but it
also
strangely enough it keeps things closed
on the king side which might be exactly
what lars needs
just a little bit of time to regroup his
pieces maybe he brings the queen back
uh defends c2 and then suddenly he can
reroute that rook over to the open e
file
that's a great idea right queen the g2
hits d5 brings the rook back around
and i like what alina is doing instead
of playing f4 and
speaking of tension that would remove
the tension of these pawns over there on
the f and g files
she's keeping that tension alive
protects her c7 with the rook
she needs to keep up the rook and f8
where it is because the b8 square and
that queen and bishop
battery can be quite powerful and look
at this a queen trade being offered
and if you're a lena do you take there
because i feel like i don't want to get
into the end game
well there's a few things to keep in
mind like there's almost rook sacrifices
that work
both of these rooks are on full-time
duty protecting c7 and b8 so
she plays the the more i guess
aggressive move queen queen h4 this is
really going to enter some
some tactical waters here the rook is
being defended by the queen and you know
everything's barely under control here
chung b6 oh my god whoa you see you
shake her head she's like oops forgot
about that pawn and that rook on b2
it wasn't doing anything for so long and
then you drop an important pawn in front
of your king
yeah earlier it you were like guys i
know some of the low-rated people in the
chat might suggest
just attacking the bond but there's an
easy defense and
queen takes a6 rook a7 wait did you see
the evaluation bar
it just went much lower because it
wait what is happening here hang on a
sec
because i think the move by the way was
rook takes e7 yes
and then there was queen a6 and bishop
takes d5 so that's what was missed
but look at the time two seconds there's
only plus one in this game and
uh rupees mate ruiz mate oh my gosh of
maiden one on the board
lose on time oh
oh my god he forgot about his clock two
two seconds is by the time your opponent
moves and
the the game it's suddenly your turn for
you to process
their move think of your move
decide on your move and execute your
move that's a lot more than two seconds
for most people
oh my gosh we should pull up that just
to show the final position
there was checkmate in one available on
the board
with rook all the way down to b8
checkmate
and look at that 18 seconds spent on
rook takes f3 and it's almost like
you just don't calculate that move at
all
and then you you would never expect a
blunder of made in one that's a long way
to go
for the mouse there robert you know as
somebody who loses them time
very regularly in my blitz games i get
it and actually perhaps
rook takes f3 was a brilliant choice by
elena in a position where
her king is in trouble no matter what no
easy moves for
lars and checkman one of course is the
best move
but hard to accomplish but as we get to
this second game here
i mean many missed tactics from both
sides as you're just pointing out this
checkpoint showing that rook takes e7
from earlier but
i think we chalk up that entire game
down to you know just
just round one that's that's what you
get in round one robert
nobody was comfortable there it's funny
to see the reactions i was actually
looking at the webcams
of the two players after that made in
one miss and we saw lars
who actually didn't get to to play it in
flag he was he was laughing he thought
that was pretty funny like
he seemed in good spirits and alina was
stone-faced like yep just
just yeah that's a win for me let's go
next game
alina is all about that serious business
in this tournament
last year she's very friendly you know
she's a great person
but she takes this seriously and she
wants to beat every single opponent
that is in front of her she is a
professional in the truest
definition of the world a word excuse me
so in how we get into the game too
she's up a pawn because of the opening
it was a banco gambit named after pa
pal benko he played this where you get a
lot of play for sakura's pawn
but i don't think this is the ideal
setup for lars because
well where are you actually getting that
play e4 is defended
a4 is your extra pawn and that's a pass
pawn i don't see the typical weaknesses
that black can target
so i'm not sure i really would enjoy
this position from lars's point of view
especially being down a point in the
match
maybe you feel some pressure to win
immediately yeah
um well first of all i think that the
idea is mainly d5 like when black plays
e6 like this
in the benko and allows white to take
he's pretty much got to get the move d5
in at some point and if he doesn't i
think it's just problematic
usually what i'm used to is black
actually plays like rook a6 and gets the
queen over to that diagonal
and that helps a lot with d5 but the way
that this has happened i i just feel
like alina has gotten a good version
of maybe a theoretical one that i'm
familiar with so
i think she should be happy here
remember these are five minute games so
lots and lots of time to dissect this
position what happens after h6
knight takes e6 c4 first question
there could be some kind of knight d4
type of move when you continue
running the knight around but i then i
see queen c5 and those are the type of
things where your knights hang in the
center of the board so
h6 actually is a good move and i don't
think knight takes e6 as possible so
you'd have to drop your knight back
but let me ask you something is h6
inducing more weaknesses and so that's
one of the reasons she went for it or do
you think she just overlooked h6
and now lars has to find it i think i
think she overlooked it
but i think it's the type of movie
overlook where you're not
that upset and he he does play it i
think she goes back pretty quickly here
realizes look this is just not playable
um
and she's not gonna be too unhappy going
back because she sees that there are
those weaknesses you talked about
yeah and it's one of these positions i
would say where you sort of trust your
opponent
h6 could be a huge blunder but knight
takes e6 you then see c4
i think she's very well aware that this
is not going to work out so she's
quickly going to dismiss that
now she's trying to figure out should my
knight go to h3 where it defends my pawn
on f2
or should i just go back to f3 where it
came from but now there could be some
issues down the file so she does
choose the retreating square that she
came from but
i could see why you would start
considering your options at that point
right and knight g4 chosen so a bit of a
different route it looks like there
won't be
d5 anymore it's more gonna be like a
knight to e5
type of game rook takes f3 is is
tempting but i think knight e5
maybe try to sink that knight on d3 with
c4 hitting the f2 pawn is the way to go
here how about the other knight to e5
because that way you could maybe throw
in a rook takes f2 check if
i i don't know if that will work but
knight takes e5 rook f2 check
does look very appealing to me yeah
that's fantastic
because now whoa now it takes king g1
and alina wants to say look no matter
how you take that back your rook is
loose there
what's going on here yeah so she can
take with the uh
he's a dick with the bishop and then she
can take the knight on g4 but then her
bishop on d2 falls here so
a lot it's really messy but black has to
be happy about this
with a very strong bishop and the white
king on g1 is in serious danger
because i would have said on the last
move when the bishop was hit and the
knight was hit like if you just move the
bishop there
something like i don't know bishop f4 or
somewhere then the knight's being hit
and
you can't move it because the the rook
on f2 but this just looks winning for
for black yeah the evaluation bar i just
saw it sync
and it's saying just completely winning
for black and
you still have to put these games away
absolutely i just don't see any way for
black to go wrong unless
you somehow hang up your g6 pawn if i
don't know how that would even happen
but it feels like it's just too easy at
this point for black to play so there's
no
concern for lars whatsoever and he will
even this match up at one game apiece
yeah it's really looking like that but
we've seen in the last game where it
came down to a maiden one
right where uh he wasn't able to convert
it just because of the time
so we'll have to keep our fingers
crossed that doesn't happen to him again
but
rook end game this is looking really
really promising for him
yes because it's essentially you know
three extra pawns in the center for that
one pass
work at six now i didn't actually like
the decision to go in the end game and
this is exactly why your rook hat
is tied down to the a pawn now your
pawns on the sixth rank there are four
of them there
and this that lonely rook on f6 is going
to start chopping them off
yeah so i i like to move rook e2 um the
engine gave some crazy brook
af1 move but other than that move taking
on g6 is logical
and i think black is kind of back in the
driver's seat like this pawn can get to
a7 but
this rook can't really help out it's
hard to make that guy queen
yeah and now this rook goes to c7 so
black's pawns are kind of stopped and
white has the more active rooks a rook
behind a past pawn
is excellent and now that pawn can even
go to a7 where the rook on c7 does
double duty
of stopping black's past pawn and
protecting white's past pawn freeing up
the a1 rook
although the king on h1 there are back
ranked checkmate possibilities perhaps
that rook
if it does leave the first rank then
black will then counter to try to
checkmate
white yep because basically after rook
a7 i mean you're always thinking about
rook b1
and rook b8 after that but this seems
difficult for
for white because i feel like when you
move that rope there's always rook a2
yeah that's true as well and that way
you can get your rook behind the pawn
and stop it
so what does white really need here i'm
trying to think which pawns you need to
pick off to have a chance to hold this
the e6 pawn
feels like an important it gets a rookie
one and after rook a2 maybe
rook c6 just double up on that e6 pawn
and try to win it
uh but even if you get that one it's
still plenty of
well the nice thing is that if you can
orchestrate that you take with the rook
from the first rank and then if king g5
you have rook g6 mate
so the king has to go back and then
maybe you can try checking forever or
something like that
that's a really good point because king
g5 here would be a great move but white
can play rook g7 check and then the king
would have to go back to f6 so your idea
about that king being in a sort of net
played a big role in that position and
that's why lars puts his king in e5
and then his king go to d4 where it's
safe and sound
surrounded by these pawns that help
shield the king
yeah and keep in mind sometimes uh if
you're not careful this king might go to
e4
and f3 and i'll almost go for some
checkmate ideas against the king on h1
this
king uh elena's king like if it was more
in the game
or if these pawns were were not doubled
they would change the position entirely
but these
pawns on the g file pretty much don't
exist and the king as she finally brings
it into the action
is just so far away uh black's basically
playing with an extra attacker
that's right and here your idea of rook
a2 speaks to me just get your rook
behind the pawn to
force white into defensive posturing you
need to defend that pawn
she put c3 first but now rook e6 to c6
yeah and now both sides are struggling
to beat
three or what but then you go rook b3
now you're in a passive setup
maybe rook takes h6 as possible i took
away your ability to play pawn to c2
and then i could run my g-pawn up the
board i would i would be worried about
this king d3 d4 connecting but yeah i
mean
i guess you just gotta trust it and just
go for it the jeep on the a-pawn
this is gonna be wild i've liked the
rook on b2 keeping the white king on the
first rank
and i thought that maybe you could try
to get that other rook in for a
checkmate i guess there was never time
to
make that work and here how do you deal
with this you're right though that pawn
just feels to me like black should win
this game is you we always
learn in chess the two connected past
ones always beat the split past puns
yeah and you're right the slip pawns are
good in king and pawn end games
because the king can sit in front of
connected pawns and stop them whereas
the
split ones the king can't get both the
same times like bowling and here in the
rook on a3
it's winning the a7 pawn by force the c3
pawn is defended by the opponent d4
once a7 falls that's very easy it's not
even split pawns anymore it's just your
double pawns in the g
file yeah very past connected pawns
yeah and this this doesn't look
promising that the eight pawn is gonna
drop you can trade a pair of rooks
chuck your rook in front of the pond if
necessary and the king and the pawns
just march up the board so i think just
trade the rooks and
you know we're only two games in but
it's too early to make any kind of big
claims but what i will say is from these
two games
lars has been more tactically alert than
alina has
and in the first game alina just dropped
that v6 pawn right it was under attack
she just didn't see it she's like what
what's wrong with me how did i miss that
of course i'm too strong
to fall for that and lars was able to
pick that off and in this game he found
knight d7
e5 taking on f2 and all that stuff so i
feel
like thus far elena you know she needs
to be a bit more cautious
in these tactical positions and i hope
she's not getting down on herself
because just two games
in two games of blitz we all make plenty
of mistakes
just getting started here um obviously
the first game is
a little bit of a the jitters there rook
a7 little uh trick at the end
but yeah just for g8 is gonna be that's
gonna be it so we have a tied match
one to one and so far i think uh i think
we're in for a treat in this match
robert as the the opening for the second
game already switched up he he didn't
want any part
of of that french at least for now yeah
i think it's really cool when we get
these matches and every game
is different because sometimes you see
great theoretical discussions and
battles
but then as commentators can we get a
new position just so
we can be as shocked as everybody else
so here this knight on d2
this kind of variation says instead of
the jibawa london type of thing with
knight c3 white can still play pawn to
c4
and elena takes towards the center but
that also means that her castling kings
side will be more difficult for black
because the king will lack one of its
shields right pawns in front of a king
help defend it
here that pawn is towards the center but
an open g-file could spell trouble
if the king decided to venture that way
yep
yeah there's always that decision you
take with the epon or the g-pawn and
this entire opening
that lars has played here the trombosky
it's is designed to quickly take that
knight
on f6 and and force black to make this
kind of uncomfortable decision so
long term positionally speaking that h
pawn is loose and
i'm not so sure about the move e4 or
even the move c4 to be quite frank
because
this d-pawn to me always is going to
require some attention and
you know that dark square bishop is is
in alina's possession and there's
nothing to match it uh
from white's position in some ways it's
hard to hold yourself back but i'm
completely with you and as you know
we've seen many queens gambit accepted
types of positions
where you want to play e4 and take firm
control over the center
but then your pawn on d4 doesn't have
its best friend on e3 protecting it you
don't get to build that pawn chain
so that's why we're saying e4 may have
been a little bit
too much too helpful for black to put
permanent pressure along the d
file and well how to go from here f5
comes to my mind i have double pawns i
don't like my double pawns
maybe i'll try to just hammer at your
center and i guess bishop h6
i have a bishop move i don't have to
play e6 and develop on that diagonal let
me use the diagonal i currently have
and get my bishop out that way yeah it's
because such a funny move bishop h6 is
like imagine you take this pawn back
and they go bishop takes d2 it's like
every
piece that you could take on d2 with
blunder is one of these central pawns it
seems
right and i think that clearly evidences
the
big drawback of playing e4 rather than
e3 is that
some pieces are she plays bishop h6 i
thought there it is they need to defend
these two pawns and the knight on d2 is
protecting e4
if you replace that 92 with the other
knight to keep e4 defended you drop d4
that's
a monster central point here and i like
black's position i think it's just much
more confusing to play this from white's
perspective
yeah i i think at this point you start
getting concerned that you're not going
to get that pawn back and maybe you
decide to go queen a4
check just take that back say okay look
let's even the material before we go any
further
and then look to just go wish me too in
castle but gotta like these two bishops
as
you know a lot of pressure on the center
that knight is going to get developed
either to
to c6 or c697 and
kingside castling for black even though
there's a g takes f6 played in this
position
i think it's fairly safe i'm with you
now i was mentioning how
you sometimes struggled the castle king
said when you move the pawn from that
side of the board but with your bishops
there and good luck attacking
the black king and especially because
the central pawns are weak
oftentimes if you're getting attacked
you can try to counter in the center of
the board distract your opponent's
forces
and that's clearly what's happening
right now and lars is
almost a minute behind at this point
alina this is for both of them it's not
a position they could have expected
this is pretty new territory and
i just feel like it's easier to play
with the bishop pair at this point
yeah and i was going to mention one idea
h4
to like trap the bishop there's always
this bishop d2 to get out of it
um and what he's done is he's just given
up that pawn that we were talking about
in the center
and he's looking to play from here i i
can't say that this looks good at all i
mean
knight c6 you got all the dark squares
and now alina could say look
i'm going to castle queenside i don't
even need to deal
with a potential attack over here i'm
with your partner
and it's kind of funny i forgot that one
of the most important roles in this
position was the bishop on g6 defending
f7
because typically the queen goes to b3
with a double attack on b7 and
f7 but f7 was already defended so queen
b only attacked one pawn that was easy
to defend
perfect and we see kingside castling
i think because if black castles queen
side
at least lars is kind of happy to see an
imbalance in the position
at least he can throw his pawns up there
but 95 hitting the bishop
again watching that f7 square just a
tender square in the position
and i mean it's looking better and
better for for alina as she's
basically collected an absolutely and
totally free pawn in the opening
yeah i think black's next two moves
might be castle queenside
which attacks the knight on d2 and that
rook on h8
can come to g8 and i was talking about
how that
open file can help whiten attack if
black castles that way
but because black is casting in the
other direction she can use her rook
to go to g8 and put some immediate
pressure on white's king
and this just looks overwhelmingly good
for elena
kashlin's guy here yeah i was gonna say
probably
castle first and then play queen d3 i
was a big fan of
but queen e3 exact same idea why
wouldn't you want to trade queens i mean
like you're you're up upon just uh we've
all learned that one of the easiest ways
to convert
whenever you're up material simply trade
yeah
and simply trade you know the one thing
that white could
potentially use the c file no there's a
knight md3 saying no c1 square for you
and this is very very good for alina but
i will say
these are the types of positions that
frustrate me sometimes where i know
i should with best play be close to
winning already
but then proving that is a totally
different story so what actual plan
would you go for here
my first instinct is rook d4 or other
other d8 and just take over the open
file
but i i'm trying to figure out what the
long term strategy should be
yeah i think i think in general i mean
like a trait of knights i feel like
would be fantastic
she's just gonna go for the the very
slow modest doubling of the rooks
um i like that this knight hits the b2
pawn so i would try to leave that night
there
double the rooks and then i feel like it
at the right moment you know once you
get like
c5 in or c6 you can start thinking about
just b5
and even collecting on b2 i agree
and for white i would consider playing
g4 at some point to try to lock in that
bishop on g6 i don't want to see that
bishop open up
after move like pawn f6 to f5 because
the bishop gets some new life
but g4 has its own wrist and you give
the f4 square to the knight and the f3
pawn
also is going to be quite weak so
uh rook d2 lara says you double i'm
going to do the same and
yeah let's let's fight for this file and
there we go f5 that's just a good move
and after this
i'm not concerned about her winning
chance anymore as soon as she gets that
move in
opening up that bishop getting rid of
her double pawns i'm all for it
so maybe something like takes takes
knight e3 followed by
f4 and you're threatening like f5 g4
um locking that bishop out of the action
and you know
if you play f6 or something then all of
a sudden this bishop e6 is
in the position that's a really good
call and i think that was
better than what just happened because
now black should play bishop e6
your move 93 was very frustrating
because the pawn f7 the bishop on b3
opens up
let me start by playing bishop e6 and
that way
if you move your knight i simply trade
bishops what were we talking about hey
let's trade pieces
we're up a full pawn and i mean
you're calling it and she's delivering
on on demand here
robert bishop e6 ready for trades here
this knight basically can cannot be
attacked
to any degree where it's going to need
to move and if it if it needs to it can
always
go back to one of these lovely squares
and it'll open up potential trades on
the d
file so this is this is tough because in
the in the last position i was thinking
maybe you start running the pawns but
now
there's not really any specific targets
uh that lars can hit in this position
and there are tactics available for
alien as well bishop takes c4 for my
knight takes b2
because that knight is defended on b2
tactically as the rook
on d2 can't move to the side otherwise
the rook behind it falls
however that would be a very committal
decision by elena because
with her bishop coming off the board the
pawn on f7 may not seem so
important but the idea being that now we
have pawns on both sides of the board
bishops tend to be better than knights
in those situations
because bishops are long-range pieces
and knights take a while to go from one
side to the other
it's a really important point that
robert's highlighting that although
black can win upon here with the tactic
he outlined
white takes on f7 and there's gonna be a
past pawn that white can create
on the king side and you just have to be
so so careful because the bishop can sit
on g8 and defend the black pawn that's
pushing while helping
a white bomb that's pushing over here so
um what just happened rook d4 knight e3
so i expect that bishop takes
b3 certainly on the cards one thing you
got to be careful of robert is now that
rook is not on a square that you can
well that's defended basically so if
that knight gets attacked
um one more time it could just be pinned
to the road
yeah that's actually a problem and i
look at the clock what's the problem for
white is not just the pawn deficit 20
seconds left for lars so
he is getting down on the clock he is
just down in the position
but we'll see if he's able to find some
kind of rook a5
rook h5 swing that rook around attack
some pawns and that's the problem with
isolated ponds the h7 pawn
it's not that easy to defend you'd have
to use a more valuable piece just to
save that measly pawn
absolutely night before rookie two
and now we see just good technique uh
from molina she's got the
she's got the rook in and
maybe just bring your work back to d3
when the b3 pawn i understand why she
traded the rooks here i guess rook d
okay she could have gone after b3 but
said she's just tying
white's pieces down and now knight f4
check rook to d3 next
i think she yeah she's got ripped d3 and
now
now once you take this pawn rook takes
b2 as a threat
or you can start with knight d3 either
one yeah
she chooses the fancy way
i i support that look good
and yeah the apon night end games so
tricky
so underrated but i feel like three
connected pass pawns they kind of worked
for lars in that last game robert
you think elena's gonna be all right
here she will but she has to watch out
for
pawn h6 for white knight f6 and if she
loses the h7 pawn all of a sudden lars
has some hope and look at the clock
she is actually down on time all of a
sudden i don't know where that came from
oh me neither but her pawns are too fast
they must be v3
is crushing yeah but she's worried i
mean she must be worried about the h7
pawn
b2 now a3 yeah we're on the same page
completely partner and that's just that
it's just too it's it's too comfortable
when you're when you're up in the
commentary booth and it's good that she
calmed herself there she was getting low
on time
that laser focused uh cam that you see
on alina catching sky
is exactly what uh helped her help bring
home the point for her there yeah
and her technical abilities have proven
very strong both in
last year's edition of this tournament
and so far here it looks good and now we
have a dutch so we
really are getting different openings
every game that's very exciting for me
and
i'm sure for you as well and for our
fans and all right this position let's
try to explain what it's all about
black has put upon f5 that could be
weakening to the king side
you look at that diagonal there could be
some options there the e6 square in
particular
if white pushes that pawn to d5 maybe
you can take advantage and try to put a
knight on e6 because no pawns defend the
squares
but iman why don't we talk about what
black has going for him in a position
like this
yeah it's really dependent on the setup
a lot of times black goes queen eight we
see queen c7
both of these moves have the same idea
you sort of want to hint at the
possibility of potentially playing e5
at some moment so knight d7 could help
that
a5 is just restricting things on the
queen side but
if you're not going for e5 a lot of
times you can play these positions a lot
slower you can sort of play like
king h8 bring your bishop to e6 and g8
and this is a really solid structure if
white ever plays e4
you're looking to take right away maybe
get that bishop out to f5 with tempo
the knight follows to d7 so it can be a
really comfortable position for black to
just sort of sit back
and wait for white to commit pawns to
certain squares as we see
already the queen side initiative by
black he says forget development
i'm pushing a5 a4 and looking to open up
that a file yeah which is just trying to
get rid of the undeveloped pieces in the
on the queen side look at that rook the
knight in the bishop so if you can trade
rooks
maybe that's beneficial but you don't
want to hand over the open file to
alina's work either so knight a6 is
played
and i guess knight d7 would have been
more
typical going towards the center but
then where would that bishop on c8 go so
black's pieces to some extent stepping
on each other's toes and look at this
alina
takes some a4 saying you know why i put
my bishop on c3
so i can push that double a4 pawn to a5
and it's going to be defended over there
yeah i think that was just an oversight
by
by lars you you generally do not want to
let this happen
when the pawn can just go to a5 and be
defended because now
she's going to plant the rook on b1
generally speaking
hit the b-pawn and lara's saying i don't
care forget the queen side i'm going
rookie
e5 as i mentioned earlier what do we
make of this i have to say lena
has got to have the better position but
you know the bishop is going to go back
to c8 from lars it's going to defend b7
so the rook on b1 is not really going to
be doing anything the rest of the game
and there's always pressure on that
d-pawn if you ever take the knight makes
it in the game
i love that move though c5 and that is
actually quite
standard in a position like this the
pawn on d6 is not defended by a pawns
defended by a piece the queen
so if i can take on d6 i will get a
tempo against that queen so that's why
pawn takes d4 for black doesn't just win
a pawn and if pawn e4
i'll throw in pawn takes d6 as well that
way i
don't allow the position to be locked up
in here don't take on c5
go take towards the center probably d
takes e5 here looks good but
i think that the tactical nature of this
should make lars feel like he's a chance
especially with the d5 square
available to that knight on f6 yep don't
forget that
both knights now have some squares to
sort of jump around to knight d5 knight
b4
um i will say i think that elena is is
just better
after taking and maybe save that bishop
or go a3
kind of looks like a funny move but take
control that b4 square
eventually white's going to go e4 and if
everything takes there the d6 square
anchored with that pawn on e5 is going
to be pretty juicy for alina if she's
really having a think here
i think she's maybe giving consideration
to pawn takes c5
um but i'm kind of wondering because if
you take on e5 with the knight
it just doesn't look right giving up d4
here yeah i agree with you and
i think another thing to point out is
the c4 square is now free you
have vacated it by pushing your pawn
forwards the knight would love to land
there
so if d takes e5 followed by knight c4
hey that e5 pawn and the a5 pawn are
both defended by that powerful knight on
c4
which is trying to go into d6 and wreak
havoc in black's position
yeah so she's giving a long think there
i think she came up with the best
uh decision overall and she wants
everything basically like she can get a3
knight c4 this game is all but over but
you mentioned how
tactical lars has appeared to be in the
match so far robert do you think he's
just gonna go for
f4 here try to get that bishop out and
just
try to get some energy going on the on
the king side because the position looks
kind of rough otherwise you mentioned
knight c4 that looks so strong
yeah positionally black is toast and
black is down a pawn so
bishop e6 i'm i'm with you i think that
an a3 you have this
completely under control i think that
even though he didn't do it right away
he
must go f4 i don't actually see an
attack but perhaps the threat of the
attack
is enough considering this is a blitz
game and mistakes happen much more
regularly in blitz
alina is a great player lars is a great
player as well
but you can't just sit here when you're
down upon the knights coming to c4 into
d6 the b7 pawn is target
your knight on a6 is a donkey because
the b4 square is now
covered by the pawn a3 so everything is
looking favorable for white
so you just need to mix it up because
otherwise you'll just get rolled over
here
if white gets to have everything that
she wants
now and i mean e3 if white gets to play
e3
as well as knight c4 this game is a role
it's it's completely over
so you have to get something going a3 is
just a
dagger move to play it might not look
like much but you mentioned the donkey
on a6
lars is probably thinking and he's like
oh my goodness why didn't i just throw
knight before it
i don't know why didn't i just play f4
when i had the chance because now i
think it's
now or never robert if not f4 i think
elena has this game she's up on time as
well
completely agreed and one more thing
i'll add queen takes a5 may seem like a
free pawn at first
but you dropped the b7 pawn and that
would be devastating so look at these
last two moves bishop e6
and then bishop back to c8 spending
about
a minute and 40 seconds between the two
and alina doesn't need to think at this
moment because well her position is so
good i would play e3
and just yeah
he's rerouting that knight to d7 trying
to put pressure there but again it's
just a
non-threat you can also play knight move
and
pawn to f4 for a while i like that move
though
knight b6 that's that's just nice ouch
the queen gets trapped if you take the
knight that's hilarious i'm just gonna
put that on the board that is a funny
looking trap
and the queen is looking at the the
knight in bishop like whose side are you
one
and you know what's funny about this
knight a8 was like almost trapping the
queen as well so
oh oh my goodness
oh she just stole the c5 pawn so the
knight going back to b8
removed the defender of the pawn on c5
and now she's up two full pawns
yeah knight g5 or knight d4 are going to
be you know some of the next moves
considered here
the d5 knight is going to be in real
real trouble i mean this is a matter of
time
i i feel like she's playing fantastic at
the moment and lars is just
he's just defending he's just on the
back foot
and knight g5 played and this is just
all sorts of problematic you win that
bishop
on e6 you trade it for that knight then
remember how we talk about the dutch it
opens up the king
look at that diagonal i would love to
take your knight on d5 and then start
putting pressure on the diagonal so just
take it with a pawn on v6 yeah
take with the pawn and then you could
even take on e6 and just go
f4 or you could start with f4 but as
soon as you play f4
i guess it's just over it locks
absolutely
all this firepower aimed at e5 that you
see in this position
f4 just says nope it's as simple as that
a one word response you know when you
ask your parents when you're younger
can i do something and then go nope yep
that's it all right yeah i'm just gonna
put my head down run back to my room
that's that yeah that's what f4 does
i'm not gonna waste my time trying to
convince this one's a lost cause
yeah i would play f4 here i wonder if
she's just trying to make sure her king
doesn't get in any future danger but
there are no pieces to attack with as
you said all of them are biting on
granite
because they're staring at the e5 pawn
which is defended by another pawn and
this
is a clear illustration of why we always
say a pawn's best friend is another pawn
a one point piece defends another one
point piece while
all of black's heavy pieces are staring
into that which is defended
and because alina is playing so well
right now
it's it's tough to even find criticism
so i'll offer one
is i feel like she's so calculated
almost to a detriment that in positions
like this where it's so intuitive
uh she eats up a lot of uh clock time
playing moves that
you could play you know kind of in a
more flowy fashion
a little bit quicker and lars always
ends up
making the game close in a time scramble
now last time
remember we looked at the clock and we
were like wait a minute how is she the
one lower on time now
she still converted the game and that's
that's definitely her style but
just pointing that out is something to
keep an eye on for the rest of this
match as
she consistently gets these dominating
positions but maybe maybe needs to play
a little bit more intuitively when she's
got
the upper hand we see the engine at
pretty much plus five right now
yeah i agree with you for example there
she could take on e6 instead of putting
her knight back in f3 she did 93 very
quickly so that's good
but some of the decisions i feel like
she can just play and trust herself and
that's
a key factor in blitz is how much
confidence you have
and are you trusting your instinct
sometimes we trust our instincts and
fail miserably right i've done that many
times where like oh this sacrifice looks
good and wait a sec nope it just fails
to this simple
response and look at this move by by
lars c5
it doesn't change the balance of the
game white is so much better here
but at least it complicates things and
that is what lars has been doing well
now he's trying to go knight d7 at some
point when the b6 pawn
guess what you can't play knight d7
there's a rook on d1 covering the open
file so
the position is miserable but it's
really what we're talking about right
now is not about this specific moment
but how this match will continue what
the trends are like
and i do think that ultimately alina is
playing extremely well here
but i'm with you that sometimes she gets
herself in a little bit too much trouble
than the position calls for this is just
surgical
at the moment there's no other word for
it i mean
every move from alina has just been
top-notch right now
and lara's even coming in with a
pre-move there bishop c4
the queen strapped oh no it's a4 sorry
it has the bishop d5 check
look at that beautiful move great and
that's going to win the
the rook on c6 actually no not quite
not quite bishop takes there's going to
be bishop takes back
and here's that 15 seconds ticking down
lars is dead in the water it's plus 10
but hey just 10 seconds left anyone can
flag is what we've
learned so far yes and she's doing a
good job because lars pieces can't move
with queens back out
but she needs to move she's six seconds
this is what we're saying
what are you doing exactly you gotta go
for two seconds i don't know
how did she even one second go oh my
gosh
she lost some time she forgot look at
her reaction and lars is like what i'm
saying
did you see lars he goes did i do that
he's like what just happened and
that was the most winning position you
could ask for
and we are going to take a break we have
that midway point
in the longest time patrol here but aman
i'm beside myself we were just
highlighting that you can't spend so
much time in positions that she should
just trust herself in
what can we make of that i i said it and
i brought it up for a reason
um because she was doing so
many good things that i mean she's not a
perfect player we have to highlight
maybe one of her only weaknesses and
positions like that
and she gets so involved with the
calculations and they're all brilliant
we saw even at the very end with 10
seconds
we were looking at bishop d6 oh so
impressive puts the queen back on e8 but
lars
he plays queen a8 in about 0.3 seconds
and meanwhile she's taking 10 seconds
for queen f7
he plays queen a6 in 0.1 seconds and
then she flags and that's
gonna be something to look in the entire
match watch out for that because
she is outplaying lars significantly
right now
but robert this cannot keep up she has
to trust herself
more in positions and start using
instincts this is blitz
after all i will just say that if you
know you believe in karmic balance the
fact that
lars lost the first game on time in a
position he had checkmated one maybe
this is
kind of payback for that that if she
loses on time in completely winning
position
i would say the first two games i would
give the nod to lars these last two
games alina has played great chess
it is a two-two match we will take a
short break and when we return we'll
have the latter half of this longest
time
five minute plus one second increment
portion of i'm not a gm speeches
championship brought to you by chess.com
well we barely had time to catch our
breath i hope the players were able to
too because amman
that was a whirlwind of a first four
games it is two to two
it's a tied match but this has seen kind
of
anything but even not by how they played
but just by
the direction of the match and alina was
on the cusp of a 3-1 lead
and all of a sudden she loses on time in
a plus 10 position
yeah and you mentioned you know a bit of
karma there
whether you think it's that or not i
think somehow
based on the chess we've seen the time
management we've seen everything we've
seen so far
somehow i feel like two to two is
exactly the score that this match
should be at so we've got that two two
match i think this is going to be a very
exciting one
uh for for people that maybe are just
tuning in we have
uh lars oscar hough against alina
catchlinskaia
and i guarantee that this is going to be
a very close one because
from what we've seen alina is capable of
completely outplaying her opponent
but also completely blundering and
flagging where where nobody should
should be doing that so
it's it's a tale of two very different
styles here
that's certainly the case and i'm trying
to figure out who has the momentum here
if you believe
in that because alina dominated that
game so from the chess player's point of
view like well that's a great game i'd
rather
be crushing my opponent and just happen
to lose in time but at the same time
you need to win it's a match and lars
just like i played some really not great
chess in that game
and i still got the point so who does
that favor
well i'll first say that lars played the
move e4
and then they went to a break and they
came back and they goes d4 so
he's getting in her head a little bit
there um
but who's who's it actually favoring i
think that lars based on his style
um is probably really happy with how the
match has gone
and um i also don't think alina is the
one to be affected by emotions
uh so to say so i don't think it'll be a
negative against her but i think lars
was saying look
as he pointed out i haven't played my
best chess i also missed the mate in one
first round
things have kind of been up and down but
the end of the day it's 2-2 right now
if i start playing better chess and
competing over the board more i'm still
gonna have
you know this natural blitz tendency
this time management that
that he's been showing the entire match
so far so i think he's probably happy
and
if he improves things work out sorry
knight b5 sighting i
saw a rook on c1 i saw queen on c8 and i
was like wait a sec the pawn on c6 is
pinned
knight b5 threatens to go knight c7
check with the fork of the king and the
rook
and if you take the knight this is a
problem
what yeah this is um
not good and if we just take kind of one
move back for a second
yeah he takes d5 is the natural reply
when there's a rook staring down the
file against the queen
but knight takes d5 had to have been
played so that you can trade off the
knights so the white knight can't get to
b5
and knight d5 is not insane either
because with the bishop on f4
you know you do have that that move
available and often played
it's often required a lot of the time so
knight b5 that's just a stone cold miss
from molina
and sort of rare in in the opening for
her
yeah and well the game isn't quite over
yet because if you play knight c7
uh the king will have to go to d8 and
then you'll take this rook on the corner
and so you'll essentially get the
situation that's what we're about to
have where
black will have a bishop
for rook white's pawn structure will be
worse white's king is still in the
center for now
so maybe it's not the end of the world
because for rooks to dominate
minor pieces you need open files and
there really aren't
many of those just yet and the rooks
aren't connected in any meaningful way
so perhaps
alina still has a chance in this game
yeah and i think lars is thinking about
knight takes d5 here
um to take back here and say look i'd
rather win a pawn and have that happen
but knight takes d5 bishop e6 i think
he's eventually going to conclude that
that's just too murky
and that's why he's going to take that
rook for sure and we get this position
look she doesn't even take the knight
because the knight has nowhere to go
the b6 square the c7 square covered this
is why knights in the corner of the
board are not good
simple math only two squares that i can
escape to it's not going anywhere so
good move i would say bishop d3
at some point alina will have to go
queen takes a8 and if that's the case
your queen's all the way in the corner
and now white's queen can try to make
progress on the other side of the board
yeah and i wouldn't hate this position
too much if i was lena like of all the
things that you could have after knight
b5
i feel like she's kind of doing as the
best she can
uh she's gonna pick up that f4 pawn i
think
yeah hit the rook um there is a rook
that can arrive to the e file but
you know white has either rook or knight
to e2 pretty comfortably
um in this position there we go and he
played 92
as you were suggesting and then castle
and he could have
he could take that pawn h7 like there
are pieces that are
loose in the position and he hasn't gone
for them because knight g3 is so quick
but g6 not only covers h7 but stops
knight f5
knight h5 then i can't go to e4 i think
the knight on g3 is horrible
and as you pointed out queen takes h7
you just start cleaning up the house
there on the king side yeah and well i
like this in the sense that
he's trying to take over the open file
and now probably queen f3
is very strong because the knight is
defended and that's the problem with uh
playing g6 he thought the king was like
on g8
so used to having the king castle that
you sort of forget wait a minute
my position is ludicrous like what's
going on and
you know what's interesting is we've
been a bit critical of alina for playing
too slowly in
certain moments she's like too quickly
right there like there was no need to
rush knight to f6
she's up plenty of time and the position
was far from over
at this point in time so uh knight of
six a poor decision
probably stemming from the fact that
she's been losing all game she had the
oversight early on i'm of eight or
whatever it was
and so she could never really get her
head into this game that's what i would
chalk this up to yeah and it actually is
um
going to be a 3-2 lead for lars and he
can credit that
pretty much to that knight b5 that we
saw so um that that opening trick
that robert pointed out that's at this
high level that's enough to win the game
for sure and we are back to a dutch so
there's something about this that lars
liked
even though we hated pretty much every
step of the way for blocks but here we
see a difference
e6 queen e7 and this is a totally
different dynamic
and the difference being that instead of
c6 queen c7
the queen's in the center of the board
the knight comes to the center rather
than over and there on a6
so he's playing more principled chess
but at the same time we still like the
situation for white because
you can play rookie one try to go up on
e4 at the moment maybe start with queen
c2 to
bring the other rook over to e1 it just
feels more flexible for white
yeah that's a great point um it's also
important to remember it's like
yeah uh you know we're wondering what
lars liked about this was he's repeating
it
it's like well i think i know what alina
liked about it maybe it was the plus 10
or the plus 11
you know that she had last time so she
will repeat this
all day i feel like until lars proves
that he has a line
that does a lot better one thing to
consider before playing e5 by black is
sometimes the strange moves c6 just to
take control the d5 square first
and then play e5 so i feel like c6 e5 is
the better order but of course e5
straight away is possible
and that's actually why alina played
rook c1 is if e5 now knight d5 has that
serious punch
because the rook is staring down the c
file that pawn on c7 so i like the way
you explained that
and she's showing exactly what amanda's
talking about and here
well maybe you have to play c6 or maybe
a6 just
to take away the b5 square because
knight b5 surprisingly
is an annoying threat in some positions
yeah
absolutely imagine e5 takes takes you
remove knight b5 it like hits the pawn
and threatens bishop a3 that's exactly
right well speaking of bishop a3 she
went for it because that pawn on d6 is
now tender
and if you play e5 you can no longer
take back with a pawn that pawn is
pinned to the queen
and by playing e5 you'd open up the
queen on d1 to that pawn d6 that would
be a humongous blunder
but d5 for white is still tempting to my
eyes
because i'm trying to get to that pawn
on d6 and i'm trying to take one of your
pawns c6 or e6 and get right through to
it
yeah so d5 i guess my instinct would be
like
e takes uh c takes and then c5 and
almost try to turn it into
a some sort of fianchetto benoni or
something all of a sudden
actually that is a serious idea for
black because
the pawn f5 is very helpful because
typically in the bononi white's pawns
are an e4 maybe an f4 you're just
crushing in the center now black is
everything under control so perhaps my
move d5
i'm tunneling on this pawn on d6 and
some kind of waiting move something that
can grow the position before you force
the action
is recommended alex what about your yeah
your moves that you mentioned queen d3
queen c2
you mentioned earlier just trying to get
e4 and the nice thing about this is that
black can't meet this with e5 before
that happens so
um d3 by the way probably better than c2
because it also stopped at b5 which was
maybe a potential idea
yeah no actually that's a really good
point so it's just
limiting your opponent's options here so
queen e3 does it all
it keeps d6 under your attention you
take away the e4 square from
maybe a 94 for block and now white can
play e4 herself
and just all of black's typical options
not really feasible here
so what is black's move at this point
that's a good question i i'll wait for
lars to maybe show me the way here
because
uh e5 not possible obviously d5 not
possible
c5 i would say possible and
maybe interesting but it would certainly
be a move that's
different than what he's been trying to
go for with his last uh couple moves he
says no
anyway did you see that she pre-moved
pawn takes b5
yeah she knew that was coming and she
pre-moved the pawn takes and then went
bishop to b4 so the pawn of b5 i guess
couldn't be captured because some kind
of bishop a6 type of thing but
that's why she put her bishop on b4 real
quick
and bishop b7 by black if knight takes
b5 hitting the d6 pawn
there might be an inter mezzo bishop e4
and that queen is tethered to the knight
on b5
and i'm not so sure that you can trust
that uh that position there
yeah all of those positions are actually
really interesting because when you take
on b5 with your knight the d6 pawn now
is under attack
but you have to really dig deep and
calculate you can't just say
oh this looks good because at a certain
point it'll be finger pointing and
counting like
wait if i go there my opponent goes
there and so on so wow look at that move
a5 another pawn sacrifice by
lars here but you know what i don't know
sorry uh what i don't love is when you
make a move as a pawn side device and
then start thinking actually
what was the plan there because you know
what white was threatening in the last
position was
knight to e5 so a slower move like a6
maybe 95 happens and there's knight c6
and if you take it pawn takes and you're
using that pin so
and maybe a5 is just the necessary move
and is he going to follow it up with b4
or
what's he thinking of because i think b4
and getting the knight involved in one
of those nice central outposts
and backing it up with the other night
might be the way to go here oh of course
but the question is why did he spend 37
seconds making that because
it's not we're not trying to roast the
guy but the thing is
of course that was his follow-up but
then maybe he saw a ghost and it was
like hey
actually before that might not be it but
it had to be the following you played a5
to dislodge
the bishop and then b4 of course came
next so that is one of those moments
where he may regret it considering he is
down
over a minute on the clock now and
sometimes what happens is you plan on
playing b4
and then you calculate a line after b4
and you're like wait maybe that's not so
good and then you take a step back
you're like wait a minute i don't have
an option
just play b4 and stop thinking about it
right trust yourself
if i'm going to think about if b4 is
good i should uh
i should have done that before i played
a5 and right here the position
is really fascinating because the bishop
on a5 is trapped
look at that knight on d5 protecting b4
covering b6 covering c7
all of that bishop's escape square so
queen to a7 if you could dart that queen
to a7
the bishop is trapped so she says let me
play e4
and blast the center of the board open
and just like in an attack you can
distract your opponent by opening the
center
okay that bishop on the on a5 is maybe
trap but if i open the center here queen
a7 there could be knight takes d6
here there's some bish knight b6 bishop
b6 one of these moves
probably saves that bishop on a5 yeah
knight b6
saves the bishop but i guess you don't
have to like i mean you don't have to
obviously allow rook a5
and drop the bishop on c8 so she's going
to start like this
there is bishop takes d5 as well
followed by
knight b6 wow she goes for that but i
mean there's also bishop c7 or bishop b6
but
so she's sacrificing an exchange because
bishop a6
yeah just hits the queen and behinds the
rook but look at the material account
what's the material white has two extra
pawns and it's almost like having
three extra pawns because the double d6
d5 situation i guess d4 is also under
attack this is
a mess this is a mess i feel like it's a
mess that
black should be you know on the good
side of coming out of this
but um as you mentioned a lot of pawns
are going to be falling i think take
takes and just
takes on d4 is probably pretty good he's
gonna go for that
i would probably i don't think i would
have traded i don't like the look of
that bishop staring down my f2 pawn
but perhaps she'll play bishop c5 at
some point although that actually will
fail
to rook takes a4 so be careful about the
sun moves
that's true bishop f4 though um followed
by maybe h4 king g2
get that rook to d1 now yeah that's a
nice way to deal with this because the
984 is trapped the bishop on d4
keeps it stuck so rook d1 perhaps is
necessary and she plays it right now
you can play bishop f2 check king takes
f2 and g5 you're
inducing that king into a pin by
sacrificing your bishop
but black doesn't have that many pawns
remaining so that could allow
true white to escape if there's one
thing that's hard to do it's win a chess
game with no pawns on the board
it doesn't matter how much material
you're up you'd be surprised how
much you rely on those pawns you don't
even think about them but in your head
there's something clicking that says oh
yeah and i'll win because this will be a
queen eventually or something
absolutely and so that means rookie four
is a smart move by the way rook takes d4
almost works rook d4 rook taking bishop
e5
hitting both rooks that cannot defend
each other but there's rook d
one check so maybe play king g2 and just
try to be sneaky
that is very sneaky king g2 like g5
might be tempting
and then rook takes d4 as an idea yes
and she does king f1 oh you know it's a
new idea it's pawn f3
to kick the rook which is the only
defender of the bishop on d4 because
king of one looks bad after g5 all right
g5 looks like it just
wins the f2 pawn by force the bishop
needs to move i take on f2
but the bishop doesn't have to move just
because it's under attack
you play this clever pawn f3 move kicked
the rook out of e4 and
now the complications alina is up a
minute on the clock here 20 seconds
approaching for lars he's got to make a
difficult decision
if not g5 here he's got to sack the rook
on f4
yeah on g5 okay and
she's going to play f3 right yeah f3 and
i think the rook just goes back
and then rook takes d4 i would not
complain at all if i had this position
for white
no absolutely and i think after taking
you take with the pawn i think you leave
your rook on d4
you want to hit the d-pawn your knight
can rejoin
i might actually play king f2 and say
take me on g3 keep my pawns connected
i don't want to lose pawn but she does
what you said and i like what lars did
quickly a rook c2 coming
and try to get a background checkmate
against the king i think you need to run
your king up
she does just that yeah and get f5 and
king f4
that's going to be crucial f5 i think is
super important here
yeah and that's something that's easy to
miss when you're trying to calculate a
variation
uh to this extent but f5 there she
played it in mind you had it covered and
now the king
escapes to f4 d5 is falling the knight
will come back in the game
and you may laugh but white might win
this game not just because of the time
but because the position after rook
takes d5 that knight comes into c5
maybe even to e4 and the black king
isn't exactly the safest king there is
no and if you play knight takes though
keep in mind there's rook check rook
check and rook takes d4 with a outside
past h-pawn
that h-pawn might be the hero in this
game because they're still winning
chances for black now that the h pawn
has been taken
i think there are chances for both sides
of this point i prefer white's position
the clock
you have three pawns in a night for a
rook
and now wait a second i feel like
they're gonna be some forks
in the near future but knight d4 should
do the trick it's so scary to
to think like these rooks are just so
poorly coordinated
rook h4 is an idea yes but now the king
can go to e5 thanks to that check there
so a4 played rook h4 king e5 let's go
king d5 only move literally the only
move
and a5 push him yeah it's got to be a5
here
remember there's oh i don't like the
look of
because the knight is very slow you
mentioned in the previous game
nice gonna say rook h1 but you don't
need to take these pawns he's getting
greedy here
and he can't take him because after rook
f5 a6 your rook can't get to the pawn a6
a7
promote me i yeah i don't think he
i don't think he realized rook for he
like sandwiched himself
very nicely then he sandwiched himself
there robert yeah just
it just had to be broke like h1 h2 and
just get behind the pawn and run that
h-bond and hope for the best
and that was a huge mistake by him and
we're back to game one
in a french but a different kind of
french we now have a
tarash and the difference being that the
position is a little bit more open
white's knight on d2 may not be the best
square for they can always go to b3
and right i guess i'm still not over
that last game i'm trying to force
myself to be that professional
commentator who moves on
when the next game begins but yeah that
was
a huge miss by lars in that game
it's true and it's it's really exciting
because every game we've seen
has had some conclusion that we haven't
been able to just go to the next game
immediately it's always something to
think about and
you gotta wonder whether these players
have short-term memory i feel like they
do
both of them seem to be going into that
next game no problem
uh whereas the time scrambles we've seen
have been seriously intense
for real and i saw lars reaction his
eyes went wide he's like
what what just happened there but in all
seriousness and in reality
it was actually never clear like i
wouldn't say that his
advantage was anything to speak of
throughout the entire game so
maybe he overestimated his position at
points and that's how you
get to this kind of position you have a
rook against a knight so you should be
better in theory but then there are all
these pawns to deal with
so i wonder if that played a part where
that material it makes you
feel confident that you should have good
winner chances but in reality
it was nothing like that look at this
move b5
says hey have a free pawn snack on that
my bishop's coming to b7
that's a juicy diagonal to work with
holy smokes and that's not the first b5
pond sack
that we've seen in this match robert so
both both players are just
willing to toss the pawn uh and and say
look give me the initiative
that's more what blitz is all about yeah
and if you castle
i was about to say if you castle
queenside if you are alina you're happy
in a sense that you don't have the
b-pawn
because what do you want to do when
kings are not outside the board you want
to attack
how can you attack sure you can create a
pawn storm or you can use
open files and without a b-pawn your
rook comes to b8 that is an open file to
work with
and it's not like the king on c1 has
that many defenders in front of it so
i believe the evaluation bar that i see
on screen here
white is slightly better but it's a very
tricky position
full of plenty of tactical opportunities
certainly i think king b1 is reasonable
white would love to play knight g3
hitting the queen but bishop takes e3 is
going to be a check and he can't take
with the queen because queen takes b5 so
either moving the bishop back which has
happened or king b1
uh seemed reasonable there rook c8 and
wow already mounting the attack as you
mentioned those open files
and look at this counter attack time
pawn and g4 comes to mind here you can
have that pawn
take it your g7 pawn behind your knight
that captured g4
will be a target and i want to point
something out very quickly is that rook
f to c8 i know the rook on a8 couldn't
get there yet but we're often taught to
bring
our rooks to the center of the board but
alina is saying no my attack is what i'm
going for queen a5 rook b8 now i have my
three major pieces my queen and my two
rooks
on the a the b and the c file and guess
what there's a king on
that's going to be one soon i imagine
that's not going to be happy to see
that configuration feases yeah that's a
great point and being able to
queen h5 to a5 uh completely changes the
scope of the position i mean
g5 by white is merely an attack it's
it's not attack on the knight rather not
an attack on the king
i don't think that that things are going
to be as quick for for lars on the king
side but if he wants to g5
knight g4 and then try to sacrifice the
knight on f6 or h6 that might be the
play
you know i was looking at some kind of
fabiano caruana style tactics with g5
and bishop takes h7 check
and just going for it and you know
sometimes you're inspired for good
reasons other times you see a great
player do something
and you're like yeah i'm a pretty good
player let me try that too and like well
that's why i am not
in that player's shoot because when i do
it it doesn't work but that's what i'm
thinking of maybe i can get a bishop
takes h7 check
and if i get the rook lift as well that
could be a big
problem so actually rook g4 is a sneaky
move at this point
if i can either the knight goes to c5
maybe there is bishop takes h7 check
rook h4 queen h5 and all this good stuff
but
i'm getting that would be funny that
would be crazy
yeah this is uh wishful thinking for the
attack i
i think a move like your king be one
move it doesn't look as good now i know
you're not we're
just at this moment because you're
walking into rook b8 and tactics on the
b
file but that's where your head goes so
it's like i mean i need to move my king
to safety but no
towards the corner of the board is not
safety in this position very tough
position i mean
knight to g4 sort of springs to mind as
getting the uh getting the knight
involved but i
i don't think that's the way you want to
go there's a lot of hanging pawns
hanging checks in the position
this is tough this is very tough both
sides launching an attack i think the
engine evaluation is just
not going to help anyone here right not
that they
know what it is but it's certainly not
going to happen wow that is a
big decision because after bishop takes
e4
now the b file is clear it's a rook b8
threatens queen takes b2 check with a
made to follow
and the bishop is now brought in to
attack the c2 pawn
if you ask me if you forced me to make a
prediction this game i think black is
going to win
yep that's what it looks like right now
just because also that bishop can just
go back
to g6 so even if the attack doesn't work
i mean you just kind of bring the pieces
to open files bring the bishop back
and you just have pressure black and
almost in a crazy world just say hey
queen takes h2 i know it looks ludicrous
but give me that free pun
your your attack is nothing it doesn't
scare me hey we're all the phenol
ludicrous here i mean queen takes h2 it
looks great so i'm i'm with you there
that
the bishop on e4 is that powerful of a
piece it's on the longest diagonal so it
goes all the way back to a8
and then hits the h1 corner while
attacking the pawn on c2
and defending h7 so queen f4 check by
the way
if king b1 there might be bishop takes
c2 or the bishop f3 is the threat so
what's happening here yeah it looks like
bishop f3 you have to go like queen
no queen e3 there's rook c4 yeah so
queen hack is going on here queen of
four
check maybe queen e3 to start that must
be the object but then
i don't trade queens i just move my
queen away to
h4 perhaps it's getting a little bit and
remember it all
rook takes c4 almost works because you
wrote c2 but
the queen is going to be hitting the
bishop so there's no rook takes f2
takes f4 it's kind of important to
remember that whenever there's a
discovered check
make sure to first confirm whether or
not you can take the piece that's giving
the check
that's a really important point because
that would look almost winning
for elena but the bishop if it were on
g6 it works the bish 24
it's under attack so the queen needs to
move but queen h4 which is what i
suggest before runs into rook d4
defending the knight in c4 and pinning
the bishop on e4 i don't like that so
much so queen f5 is the only other way
to keep the attack going and knight d6
would look scary
but now rook takes c2 check is a cool
move because
the knight forks the house after queen
f5 96 but c2 hangs the check
then i move my rook out the way and
there's another check and that should
pick up material for elimination yep
and c2 is hanging uh the knight is
hanging
it looks like maybe a rook d4
kind of has to be played you lose this
pawn but sometimes when the bishop takes
in front of the queen
it's not the best coordination to have
like all of a sudden white
starts to get a few tempe yeah that's a
very good point
and if you could somehow get that knight
to feel defended so you don't have to
worry about it every turn
white will then establish some control
over the board here
but not when you lose the c2 pawn i mean
that's a very scary pawn to drop but i'm
with you that rook d4
looks like the move that may have to be
played and what's funny is that the rook
d4
and bishop c2 maybe queen e5 or
something like that is possible perhaps
not queen e5 but the point is
if i trade queens there there's no
pieces on light squares
so you have a discovery with a bishop
but nothing to win literally everything
would be on dark skirts that's hilarious
knight d6 also jumped out at me maybe as
a possibility on that last turn just
because again
speaking of taking the discovered
checker
you know that knight d6 hits the rook
that's the piece that's giving the check
not the bishop so
um but there's six was definitely
possible
some kind of bishop b3 queen c2 mate
right like the bishop would have moved
out the way and
the queen would have landed where that
bishop came from so you know you're
right that
you are attacking the checker and look
look what he did
he somehow has kind of escaped but now
what
i'm looking at the clock he's down a
minute on time i see the eval bar black
is doing extremely well
if knight takes e5 here rook c2 check or
rook takes c1 and queen c2 mate
something like that is just devastating
so e5 is a very good move yeah i have to
give elena credit the queen can't take
because f2 follows the check
and the position collapses so it's
looking great for alina
and she's up a minute and 10 seconds and
this
you know we've talked about this before
don't want to jinx her she needs to play
confidently and not get herself in time
trouble to match
lars's clock yeah something's like rook
d8 i was going to say and then
remember if the piece is exchanged and
the king goes to e2 you always have like
bishop b5
just increasing the pressure basically
if alina ever gets an h5
in to have a king a safety square some
luft
that that's going to be the end of the
game king on c3
this is crazy b3 next lars he doesn't
care he's got seven seconds he may as
well go for it
and look at him with rookie through
check oh walks right into it but
it's maybe it's not the end of the game
like
after rook d3 track you have to give
your queen you get the bishop so
materialist materially speaking black is
of course a head
but there could be some universe where
the a7 pawn drops and all of a sudden
like queen takes g5 though yeah
that's that should do it because now
when you play h5 and there's no there's
no g
pawn in the way so i and that the a
pawns are double there's no way to get a
pass pawn
i'm feeling pretty confident here for
for alina just play h5 or something
i'd feel much better about white chins
if you could put a bishop on e3 rather
than
not to take the queen but just to defend
more of the border the bishop
is strong in attacking one side of the
board while defending the other
here that's not happening and the a7
pawn will survive
so with that being the case alina should
be able to put this one away
yeah queen c7 even
or queen d6 is better yep okay
just picking everything up
how many pounds you have just two it
looks like more
yeah it feels like more i i think at
some point
she needs to take the i would take the a
pawn okay and it's gonna be resignation
yeah he says look just just go next go
next i've had enough of that position i
had enough for that game
and when elena is is on she's really on
robert like when she wins it's a
beautiful game start to finish alina
took control ever since b5 i feel like
black had the initiative and was
dictating the tempo
so i mean it's really impressive when
elena puts that full
game together it's more about the clock
and time management
those are the areas that she seems to
suffer in sometimes
i'm with you there and we're back to the
dutch
in a different version of the dutch
because the bishop's on e7
rather than on g7 so it's just
interesting that even when we have the
same starting moves we get a unique
position
and here we see e4 we talked about this
the first time we saw the dash
you blast open the center and guess what
black's pieces are quite passive here
look at the bishop on c8 bishop on e7
and the pawn on e6 is going to be a
long-term target if you take on e4
that's not exactly pleasant for block to
deal with
yeah and even though you can toss in the
move knight b4
white's just going to retreat the queen
e2 and take back all the same
on on e4 but this is a natural freeing
move but i don't
think that it's necessarily the
the worst thing for black to allow i
mentioned some sometimes taking
everything on e4
is exactly what uh the dutch player
needs
to free the pieces like sometimes you
you take everything
and there's some sort of knight b4
followed by d5
give your knight that d5 square you give
up the e5 square but you get a square
for yourself so knight
before is going to be played and we'll
have to see what the follow-up is
because
i think it's got to be taking and some
sort of e5 or d5 break
in the center to gain some space e5 hard
to play once you remove the knife from
c6
because it might just drop a pawn and oh
wow okay so
bishop f5 is the idea so tactics
everywhere
i'm with you now i underestimated this i
was i was thinking about the material
but bishop f5 getting the c2 the d3
square under control
that is actually pretty scary and when
he played that move he
he sat back like he he it's almost like
that
that move had some kickback to it like
as soon as he played it he's
he started rocking back in the chair and
he is is
ready for the tactical skirmish that's
about to occur here
and it's about even the clock this is
what happens in these long time control
games i was thinking that we'd be down
to a minute left per player and then i
look and they still have four minutes
left i'm like oh wait they actually do
have time
to think because we just went right from
a finish where
there's not much time to all of a sudden
okay let's breathe let's figure this out
so
now that we're trying to do that can i
take on e5
knowing that bishop f5 is coming she
does that but where's her queen going is
she going to take on b7 as well
no she sits on wait knight c2 with a
fork queen
c2 queen d5 check king h8
is is sort of the expected variation
there and then
is it going to be something aggressive
like you know getting the bishop out or
is it
really going to be that that rook you
want because rook b1 looks like night
before back
and you just lose a full rook yeah this
uh
this doesn't look ideal but we've seen
her play an exchange down before
i think she wants to take on d6 and if
bishop takes then like bishop g5 with
tempo
and then she would get a rook out safely
okay and what if you take with the queen
on d6
oh didn't quite get to that one and we
don't need to it's okay we don't just
exactly
like that line didn't exist we had it
covered so
now the e5 pawn at the very least black
should be able to make a draw on those
variations of knight c2
move the knight back away and the rook
on b1 will be hanging so that's why she
played bishop g5
but i'm kind of concerned she's playing
more for a loss than a win
and it feels like black's pieces are
perfectly situated the rook on d8
can go down to d2 at some point soon the
bishop on f5 is doing great the knight
on b4 is excellent
so isn't black better and the evil bar
seems to indicate as much
um yeah here even like i think maybe you
have a choice between h6
c6 all those kind of moves seem pretty
decent h694 rook d4
might just be a good way to get doubled
with tempo
and and yeah even though there's an
isolated bond there you have to look at
the piece
activity black is enjoying an open
d file an open f file um as we see in
room d4 played
and yeah it's knight c5 i think just b6
or
c pawn will be loose after that all
right take c4
where does the knight plan to go well b6
rook takes c4 there could be a3
and some bishop d5 check so you have to
be careful if you're large before you
take that pawn on c4
as uh there will be that check on the
diagonal and picking up the rook so
that's a good point i think i would
start with this and then reevaluate
throughout c4 because b6 is
under attack right now and after b6
there's no there's nowhere dangerous
that the knight
seemingly can go i yeah and i did not
like this move because now if knight
takes b7 the knight is safe over there
a5 is hanging
and i want to keep my a pawn i want to
take on a5
and then promote that a pawn thanks to
the bishop on g2
oh g2 long range
although i i just caught myself because
bishop d3 is a threat for black trying
to win the f2 pawn so
it looks like there's that outside
past pawn that will go well for you but
black has the initiative right now
and you need to watch out for mission d3
yeah bishop d3
is the idea knight
i guess knight d3 could be played here
but i have to admit that that is a
pretty brilliant move and
the main purpose of that is to fill the
d3 square
yet knight d3 looks menacing hits b2
hits f2
but much scarier was bishop d3 to
dislodge the rook's defense
and so you're willing to give up b2
you're not willing to give
f2 and if knight takes b2 now perhaps
just rook to c1 try to trade off a pair
of rooks
and again the a3 pawn wants to dart down
the board
with the help of those minor pieces yeah
and now
i mean not playing d6 from lars is maybe
just trying to keep the position
too tactical because he had a positional
approach there b6
solidify secure those bonds and then go
forward against white's weaknesses
but here it's like everything is just
getting treated left right and center
we've talked about discovered checks
a lot this match knight takes up two
everybody takes and there's no good
check again
that's right you know another example of
that
and if that's the case and the pawn f2
isn't directly under attack
i was gonna say can you push the b pawn
and the f2 pawn though
this is so rich this position
losing f2 the end of the world or is it
just hey if you take on f2 you're also
sort of stuck
because i would like to trade one pair
of rooks from white's perspective
because then your attack won't checkmate
me and black would love to put that rook
on f8 down on d2
or on b2 whatever and take on f2 you
want to mow down the seventh rank
but that's not happening so i think that
you're okay giving up that pawn even if
it's not preferable
and then that a3 pawn watch out for it
yeah it's almost like if the knight
could take on f2 and
you could sort of get this e pawn going
that would be ideal but
it's not it's not that easy to do
because i mean the rook stops this pawn
very easily
and remember these rooks are not both on
the on the second ring
right so there's no discovered checks
there's nothing like this in fact
they're not really
coordinated that well at all actually i
like
a little knight journey here for white
knight d4
the rook moves to d2 then knight to e6
the rook moves to
defending the knight on f2 the knight f4
blocking the rook's defense of that
knight and hitting the bishop on g6 so
this could actually turn south very
quickly for
lars here yeah yeah that's a great point
i think you have to choose
f6 because you have to defend this
bishop otherwise it might even just be
losing a piece after
right and now i think that elena has a
choice
the c7 pawn was hanging but she plays
knight f4 and now look at this knight d5
the pawn moved opening the bishops
defense of the d5 square
hitting the rook hitting the e3 pawn
rookie six defends the pawn or
well can i still capture it because the
knight on f2 loses defender this is just
great night hopping yeah this is
beautiful alina she played it on a dime
too she had that whole pattern that
whole
uh root mapped out she was ready for e3
knight d5
boom and it's like this knight on f2 it
looks so menacing but she's unfazed
it's right beside her king there's some
threats but she says look it doesn't
matter i've been moving one piece
the last four moves and exposing the
lack of coordination in black skin
and look at the last uh moves 24 through
28 these last five moves
knight b3 knight d4 96 knight four
knight d5 that knight
came from a5 and then just said hey i'm
gonna go three squares over there to d5
that took
a long journey but she did it with tempo
after tempo
and now the final tempo is just so
powerful hitting this rook on
f6 this pawn on e3 white is winning
material and then that a3 pawn can
finally
shine and the bishop is open all the way
down to the
edge of the board yeah and this this is
crunch time for for lars there's
97 there's knight e3 sorts of good moves
here yeah get rid of that pawn
immediately and by the way the 93
protects the bishop on g2 so
even if black is somehow able to throw
that rook on f8
down on b2 the knight covers the bishop
so it's
not even a huge threat at the moment so
just move the rook
to e1 i like defending the knight king
h-shape and now a4 a5 a6
a7 question is why does this not just
win
that's basically what she's asking
yourself right now
but don't ask for too much longer
because exactly we've seen this before
remember this is actually gonna be the
last game right of the
the five minute portion so if she goes
in
to the break with a two-game lead
that'll be the first i think the first
two game lead of the match would be
super super important
yeah she could have had a 3-1 lead
remember she lost on time in the fourth
game
heading into the break so this would be
the first two game lead of the match
you're correct
and well look at that knight on g4 rook
coming down to f2
this is starting to look a bit
uncomfortable so she needs to find it
several accurate moves and if she's able
to then
she should have the huge advantage so
whatever i assume the knight's gonna go
back yeah
i was also thinking if could you bring
that rook down to f2 from f8 and try to
checkmate along the second rank
yeah i think for now with 14 seconds
he's maybe going to repeat and and use
the time that alina is spending
to think because he knows i think that
alina wants to play for the win here
that's been the case
you know that's the direction the game
has been going but time ticking down
we've seen
lars excel in these situations and looks
like she's
willing to repeat moves he's thinking he
he's trying to play for win perhaps
because he hasn't moved it there it is
you cannot take on g4 well you can but
after a move like bishop takes f1 you
cannot take
back on f1 because that's your typical
checkmate with rook g2 rook h2
okay what's happening here bishop is
getting so dicey bishop
g6 oh wait the bishop was hanging i
thought it was mate for white all of a
sudden
bishop could be captured okay so rook f2
okay you need to save your king and now
rookie eight and the pawn is just trying
to run now alina is not worried about
like getting mated or losing this game
because she's done a good job containing
the rooks i think
brook c2 and great move yeah she's going
to be up a pawn here
should be a draw but um she's she's done
a great job so as much as uh
as she can and only she has the winning
chances here although
with the time the way it is oh rook b2
maybe and
yeah brookie 2 g5 g4 you're kind of
trying to check me at the white king
a little scary there after the game i
would like to highlight that rook c2
moment oh
what oh my gosh yeah that would have
turned things around real quick h4
shotgun
wait h4 put the king in the game and put
the king in a meeting net oh no she
could like lose this now
yep we cannot wait to analyze this
though she could lose this after king h3
rook check oh my gosh oh it came back
the rookie jade chad was a threat h3 h3
that wins
king g3 and then king takes yes take and
then just your king moves out king f6
and then the rook check is a threat to
get a queen
yes like my gosh run run run
that's gg yep and now brook g8
anywhere yeah
i'm sorry excuse me not anywhere that's
true
that's true actually that there's the
only square the rock could move
in the game it was like anywhere oh yeah
just the only move on the board
rook anywhere obviously oh well let's
just analyze very quickly
a couple of those moments uh if you
don't mind we can go back to the moment
rook c2
and i think that that was a really
instructive moment
because i think most of us are so
focused on our a3 and b4 pawns
that we we tunnel we're like oh my pawns
are under attack
but the problem is you're going to lose
one of these pawns regardless a3 is
under attack
and if you play rook f3 then rook takes
b4 happens
and your a8 rook isn't defended so you
are losing a pawn
by force on that from those two uh files
so she plays rooksy two giving up one
pawn to go up upon up ending
and then i mean as we go forward from
there i'm on you could take the wheel
because there was like a checkmating net
for
white and also for black it was wise
this was i mean the evaluation bar
is is just going up and down all over
the place so rook v8
was the first i would call a pretty
serious mistake
because i think you should just throw an
h3 check kick that king back
um and the reason is that black can
throw in the check here this is what
robert and i were both
gasping at because you always want to
check uh and force your king your
opponent's king back where possible
so rook jack the king would have to go
back somewhere here and then king h3
there's never going to be any checks to
that king and if you're not careful all
of a sudden you might be losing both of
these pawns as white
and maybe get into some trouble so that
was miss and then b7
so now whenever whenever the pawn is
there robert it's all about
hey can this rook ever move anywhere
with a check because that'll always be
winning
right and then when rook b4 was played
which was a big mistake h4
check is beautiful and the point is if
you go to f6 or h6
i simply give you a check and then my
pawn promotes with the defense of the
rook i go up a rook
and if you go king to g4 because that's
the only other move that doesn't allow a
check it's the only move rook f8
and if you take the pawn there's rook f4
checkmate the king is ensnared
in a mating net and there's nothing
black can do to avoid it because the
best you can do is give up your rook for
that pawn to avoid the mate
but i don't even think you're getting
that far just really beautiful stuff
there
and i you know i saw it i had the idea
in my head but then the eval ball went
and i was like okay it has to be h4 and
the mating net there is just devastating
that's that's like a one you might find
in puzzle rush absolutely
yeah and uh but yeah that that that game
was just wild that was probably the
biggest miss
um that we saw there in that one and
robert
it's it's gonna be that two point lead
as we go
into the break from the five minute
portion
i mean what are your thoughts on the
match we've seen so far because
every game it feels like the time
scrambles uh that we're seeing
are so intense every single time for
sure and i think if you're
alina kitchen you have to be very happy
that you just won a game in a time
scramble because in the back of your
head
in a match with this kind of format
you're thinking bullet section bullet
section
even if i'm up three games on the match
score what if i'm the underdog
and my opponent just wins all those
bullet games but now you just prove to
yourself and everybody watching
that you can win a time scramble and
you're not just going to make mistakes
and
fall apart so that's great she's up two
games lars he's right in the thick of
this this is not that big of a deal
she has to be the favor at this point in
my opinion but he is the favorite bullet
player
and as we get to three minute amman i
feel like his chances should start
improving
with the quicker time patrols yeah
though that's going to be the next that
uh stage as we have the three plus one
portion of this match the players are
gonna take a break as they get set for
that
and robert and i are gonna do the exact
same thing so everybody calm down and
we'll be right back with the next
portion after the break
and while we're in the midst of an
enthralling match we should let
everybody know that there is another
great event coming up
starting in february it is the pogchamps
3 presented by grip six it's going to be
another great event
featuring celebrities and popular
streamers you see here
in the graphic in front of you you have
xqc returning for a third time bloodwick
makes his reappearance after starring as
a commentator moist critical
and we have a lot of first-timers here
mr beast myth
rayne wilson yeah you're better known as
dwight schrute huh
pokemane code miko and daniel negrono
the poker legend
michelle carey and of course logic who
is a fantastic rapper
and also an avid chess player so amman
any early favorites from your
perspective or anyone you're kind of
rooting for or just curious to see how
they do
well i think it's great that you got
some of the favorites returning
uh to the pogchamps tournament but then
you also have tons and tons of new
people
um joining up i know logic has been
streaming a lot of chess lately
um i think that it's gonna be
interesting to watch the
sort of outside twitch uh participants
such as rayne wilson such as daniel
negranu
um such as logic take on people who are
more comfortable on twitch and have been
streaming a long time like
myth pokemane and all those streamers
that we know so i think that's going to
be the most exciting thing to watch
who's going to do better robert it's the
mini game
is it the twitchers or is it the people
outside twitch so i'll be looking
forward to that
it's a great question and what we're all
looking forward to is the next part of
this match
it is three minute plus a one second
increment time control
elena casting sky leads five to three
and we're off as soon as we start
talking about the games have begun
alina gets the black pieces again and
amman the question that i'm wondering is
what is largest first move going to be
we're back to a french yeah and he wants
to give this one another go
um there's no reason why he
shouldn't be interested in that and he's
already switched the variation up
or uh i should say maybe alina did no i
think elena played
um bishop b4 last time so it was alina
who changed the variation
she did and that's what happens when you
are watching players of this caliber
and for everyone who's tuning in why do
they keep changing their openings is
there something they don't like
they're capable of playing many
different lines and that keeps their
opponents on their toes look at this
b6 then g3 let's have a stare down the
bishops with the knight in the way and
if we quickly show bishop b7
bishop g2 f5 it looks like wait that
knight can't move
you lose the bishop on g2 but it can
move with check and that's why alina
starts with pawn f5
so she can be first the diagonal
yeah and something seems a bit off here
if i if i can just say that the
f5 knight back bishop b7 and does white
have to play
f3 you could potentially d5
and sacrifice a pawn that is somewhat
thematic but f3 was played and that i
don't like
this looks bad all right this is not
good um
there's almost like ideas like knight c6
where bishop f6 hitting the pawn
knight e2 is not possible and then if
you castle there's an idea of bishop to
g5
pinning the queen and if f4 you already
pick up that rook in the corner
such a good point the castling queen
side just could lose in exchange right
away
for and i think that's the idea oh
that's nice i need to pick that pawn up
and
castle bishop g5 is a real idea
wow uh so that doesn't look good so
what it's a rook d1 played yeah so there
we go we're already seeing
the weirdness that this position is
yeah this doesn't look great for white
and look at this because
white's position has taken so much time
just to get here
elina castles and that may seem like
she's walking into a potential attack
but she has the bishop pair and the
bishop on f6 is unopposed and going to
make use of these dark squares
and i love the idea of queen c7 or queen
c8 here
uh not trading and instead keeping the
position tactical i think the dark
squares for white
the only option being castle and king's
side are insanely weak
so queen c7 i was a fan of i also
like that and well she's playing quickly
she is slightly ahead on the clock here
she's bringing her night out she's fully
developed
and i didn't like the move castle by the
way i think king f2
was more precise we're in an end game so
your king should be closer to the center
now it's not a pure end game there's
still some attacking chances but king f2
looked better to me than castling right
yeah because i mean maybe you want to
play king e1 at some point maybe
the king goes to f1 but f2 it would
already be defending that pawn
i can i can basically agree with you uh
simply based on that robert imagine the
king on f2
it'd just be better placed and we're
probably going to see that in the near
future
the king coming to f2 and look at this
knight f3 check a possibility that
wouldn't have been allowed had the king
been on f2 now black has the pair of
bishops but let me ask you something
here
what can those bishops attack the
knights are defending each other so
can white just try to trade off the
rooks and say your bishops are kind of
useless
yeah i think i think in general the the
bishops should be a bit
better in the same game but knights are
so tricky in blitz and i completely
agree with the idea
of just trading everything off there and
alina agrees as well because she says
no that's not gonna that's not gonna fly
here bishop c6
the you know the d file is yours but
rook d6 maybe rook c8
kick that rook out immediately and and
then regroup and bring the king towards
the center
this is a great lesson in knowing what
pieces to trade and both
uh you know iman and i were kind of
hinting at this you do not want to trade
all the rooks off alina says
yeah i agree let's keep a rook on
because now this rook can poke and prod
rook v8 hits the b2 pawn maybe can jump
into the b4 square
and cause some problems for white and as
though
white is the first the punch on the d
file that rook is going to be kicked out
and then the king can walk to the center
and look for h5h4
on the other wing and this rook on c8
will be valuable as the game continues
and i think that black might consider a
move like c4 at some point because
i was going to say with that pawn on a2
if white got c4
that would be ideal for his position but
now that we see bishop b6 with c4 coming
i'm really liking the way lena is
treating the bishop pair here
agree it again and c4 there is b4 for
white you do not want to take that pawn
on c4 because the rook on c8 was like
hello good to see you here
and we'll win that one right back so i
think that white needs to keep the
position closed there but look at her
playing on both
sides of the board guess what bishops
outclass knights
when they're pawns on both sides and for
in the future f6
e5 let's get a pass pawn right down the
center
yeah love the way that she's playing
here black is just so much better
there's h4
there's c4 now c4 there's no b4 move
which you pointed out because a4 is
hanging so
it could be time to get that movement
and yeah she's focused on the king side
right now and she wants to take on g3
play rook h8
get the rook down the line uh there
because the bishop one c6 covers the
whole diagonal and
she's i just love the way she's doing
this it feels like
white is just struggling to even come up
with an idea here and the bishops are
promising and looking in all directions
yeah that's
that's like that's a grimace for me not
like the look of c3 just the rook on v8
it doesn't matter if it works now works
later that is gonna hurt
uh white's position eventually yep
and knight c4 bishop c7 you probably
have to do something like knight c1 or
rook to b2 but either way
f6 or bishop d5 those are the moves that
come to my mind here
and how can white continue h8 too
is a way to get all the way around the
position
because the g3 pawn that's why h5 h4 was
played by alina
g3 is this the soft point now rather
than h2 which couldn't have been
attacked so
rook g1 for instance will force that
king to f2 but then maybe there's rook
g2 check so
actually after actually one how do you
defend g3
yeah beats me uh rook g1 looks
quite strong here um i mean c5 is
hanging
let's not forget but after you play
knight c5 i'm not too sure what the
follow-up is
right so knight e5
that sounds about safer than bishop e
yeah they say well now bishop d5 is
better because
there's no c4 to kick the bishop out and
oh
can you wait rookie seven no
oh my god what it's still there
oh my gosh and that's how a great
position turns into a horrible one
just losing sight of the d7 square
oh my goodness b3 is hanging
there's going to be endless checks here
by the way wait
that that was completely unexpected i
understand how this happens in a blitz
game but
white's up a piece was there no way out
no you had to go to g1 and then play
knight f1 no i'm trying to think how do
you get out of that
wait sorry don't you just go to g1 h2h3
we can we can show uh on the analysis
board real quick while these next
that's like that was weird couldn't you
also
yeah that's so strange what happens if
you go
all the way here i
i don't know oh over h1 so so
knight f1 which is what you said before
is good because the knight e5
yeah let's read about f6 though or the
knight c4 back to d2 or something like
that
ah that's good that's good
yeah he's not much time though he didn't
have much time and
honestly that was the weirdest kind of
draw but it just sort of happened
well this game should not be a draw by
the way that one happened
look at this position where we we just
tuned back in
yeah bishop takes g6 and just checkmate
in the next few moves
by the time we figured out why that one
was maybe drawn
it this one's almost over by checkmate
so we gotta be careful these three
minute games are going so
much quicker than the five minute
portion and bishop g6 knight d5
is in the position the queen to the h
file i mean this has to be a good attack
and simply knight takes d5
queen e6 check you can just move your
knight back to e3 so you can steal that
pawn
and oh you could even go you could even
go knight
e2 almost with like some bishop h7
trickery i don't think it quite works
but i wanna i want your queen to take on
d5 and then i have some bishop h7 checks
but right
doesn't look like it's quite so working
does go for it yes or she does go for it
yeah she takes and now 93 back and
well she's what's the material i haven't
even looked black only has three pawns
left
and white currently has five so two
extra pawns but that's not the
important part of the story it's that
the king on g8 lacks defenders and after
knight back to e3
white's next one will be knight to f3
and likely knight to g5
and good luck to your king on g8 yeah
it's a hilarious position there's just
no point i talked about winning a game
without any puns well
black on move 16 has already given up
five of them and
this is the kind of thing you need to do
if you're large is somehow get some
counter attack going you're looking like
you're getting checkmated
on the king side can you try to muster
up some counter play i
i don't see it just knight g5 yeah
knight g5
and i'm wondering where this queen ends
up getting to
queen e5 queen ah maybe
yeah queen e5 there's no actual
follow-up i want to get my queen into
the game for white but i don't see a
wave four then i don't have six is
covering everything
yep so maybe we start with bishop f5
actually
where's your queen going yeah it looks
like
f seven and then knight g5 bad knight g5
and then bishop b6 that's game over
oh that's game over oh my goodness and
it was a process of elimination thing
here and she plays bishop five
this is you're winning the question this
is the type of moment
where alina's style of being so
calculated and so precise
is exactly what just wins her the game
on the spot here she's not playing
knight g5
on a whim she's saying look how do i
absolutely crush this position
bishop f5 she realized is forcing bishop
e6 and that is completely over
just as straightforward as he gets and
we tuned in sort of late to the game
but as soon as we first looked we see
okay it came from this kind of banco
gambit
black is down some material but normally
there is a result you getting checkmated
in the first 20 moves
in fact black is the one who's supposed
to be attacking because you give up
pawns
for quick initiative
yikes this is and how do you think he's
going to continue playing because
it's either resign or you got to sack
your queen for like the best amount of
material possible
it's one of those moments where you just
give up and yeah the variation itself is
one that
is extremely dangerous because white
just pushes all her pawns forward and
that's what happened and we're back to
here bishop f6 gfc okay
he's not going to play g3 this time
there's no way
no you're right you're right no way
that did not work out for him last time
not even a little bit
and here it's another example of
throwing in the check which is meant by
an easy block and then retreating the
bishop because you closed down the
diagonal look at this the bishop comes
to f3
just like it was trying to go to on g2
except now you don't have to create
problems on your king side so your
bishops is
nice and calmly here still though black
can play f5
bishop f6 and i think this is a good
position for black and i can't believe
i'm saying about that again
about a french on move 12. i know
it's uh it's blasphemous but uh the
position is
is solid because c5 is gonna happen at
the right moment f5 is always there
long castle looks solid i feel like f5
followed by
c5 is really gonna be a good position
for
for alina yeah and there's so many
tactics as well knight to e5 for black
the rook on d8 says
i'm willing to stare down with the queen
all the way there on d2 and
so there's a retreat 95 still speaks to
me where's your bishop going
maybe okay she says team b8 still 95
still there 95 bishop e4
there's like f5 to follow up knight c4
or knight
g4 in that position finally we do see
your move robert
you're getting some credit around here
i'm feeling good about it and
now c5 feels powerful if the bishop
leaves the f3 square
the only square you can go to is h5
which puts some pressure on the
f7 pawn but the knight e5 it protects it
so it's not a threat
right there and i think you play c5 and
open all your pieces up
although c5 is a bit dangerous because
if black does play c5
there'll be knight b5 ideas for white so
just because we've been
focused on it doesn't mean that you
necessarily have to go for it and
i would refrain at least for the time
being from playing the move c6 to c5
yeah it looks strange but bishop h5 is
probably exactly what white
needs to do in this position and queen
e3 just
just feels like it has to be wrong right
queen d3 might run into bishop
a6 problems for that queen there and
queen c1 speaking
having to be wrong putting the queen
back on c1 and look at
lars you saw that he just grabbed his
head threw his hair all over the place
and now he's like uh so when do i when's
it my turn when do i get to start
pushing you back
yeah exactly he's in uh full
full focus mode because i mean i know it
looks crazy but
you know i'm looking at queen takes h2
i'm just letting you know
i'm checking it out i actually was
thinking the same thing
as soon as you move a piece you think
what has changed well the rook was
defending h2
and elena puts her king on a8 so
what is her idea why is she putting your
king all the way in the corner
there's never going to be some kind of
like you know rook usage
on that side of the board like rook b8
doesn't add to the
position at all so i don't really fully
grasp what she's been doing
and yet i still think her position is
totally good
yeah absolutely like knight 92 i
understand what lars is trying to do
he's just trying to trade things off
like
if these knights disappear and he gets
c3 in maybe g3
um long term that h pawn over there is
something to worry about in an end game
and if you ever play c5
i don't think that he's going to be too
upset trading those light square bishops
and getting rid of the bishop pair
for alina so i understand what he's
doing he's saying look let's trade
pieces
because i don't have a lot of space and
this is really going to help me uh
finally get to move and he takes up the
rook he didn't want to walk into any
sort of pins and bishop g5 was a threat
so what rook d3 was played
and lars is well ahead on the clock here
and queen h6 could come at any moment so
it's
now all of a sudden the dynamic has
changed completely queen h6 is what i
would play here
saying my queen sitting on c1 not doing
all that much but he sits on
e3 instead yeah i think he can throw in
g3
at the right moment to sort of solidify
everything also knight c1
to b3 to c5 was an idea and maybe what
what prompted elena to play a5 say look
a4
i'm going to control all these queen
side squares you can't use them
right and i still like the queen going
to h6 but
perhaps okay rook d2 i i'm trying to
grasp what like the idea hit
here is and one of the ideas i'm
thinking about for white is playing rook
c1 c3
but you didn't need to make those last
few movies of g3 and rook back to d2 so
i guess that's not what's going to
happen
but i'm just looking at that c6 pawn as
a potential target
what do you think of c4 here and then
knight takes c3
with the idea knight a4 to knight c5
anyways king a1 was played so oh
i think it he did want to do it but he
wants to take with the pawn
okay well that does make some sense
although the b
file doesn't look like a disaster i
wouldn't recommend opening it it feels
it gives white
too much play and easy play and look at
the clock situation
lars is well ahead on time so i would
not want to
make his life easy so bishop a6 hits the
c pawn
if c5 thank you for all of the light
squares your opponent d4 is permanently
at target
so i think that well what do you what do
you do here really for
rook c1 i guess but i don't like that
either
well c5 and like i don't know knight
f4 next or something play c1
knight c1 doesn't feel like the right
one no i'll put it that way
and i like this move bishop c4 a lot
saying that knight wants to get into the
game
no and i can play bishop d5 and look at
your pawn on d4
i am stopping that pawn's progress
entirely and i'm going to pile all my
pieces
and try to win it later knight takes e2
though
and suddenly that pawn is very well
defended and
like rook d5 there's always knight f4
right
so the cranking off to b5 it's just
slithering into the position
yep what is queen h6 going to happen or
is it never going to happen
it might just never happen but now it
seems like a great
opportunity to just throw it in there
right because
just like h2 was hanging in white's camp
before h7
maybe can be captured depending on how
the game gets used this
he wants to plant the knight on b3 just
some stable square which i
totally understand knight b3 covered by
the pawn guards d4 and then maybe he's
comfortable finally playing queen h6
yeah i like this much more now watch out
for that c6 pawn
so she's just sort of moving she's
playing quickly she's ahead in time now
and i do not like f4 i really don't like
them it locks in your queen
so there's no counter shot
okay and they each have you know 20
seconds ish a piece
there's pressure on d4 but honestly this
is a tough position to break
break through like maybe you run the
king all the way to the king side or
something and switch the rooks
okay well she's starting with the the
rooks and then i like your idea king d7
king e8 run over there so queen f3 at
least gives the idea of queen h5 at the
right moment
but i would start running that king
towards the kingston like you said
yeah oh okay maybe she's
noticed that queen on e2 hit the queen
on b5 i feel like she didn't notice that
is the king about to walk in kingdom
oh my gosh yeah it is and
rook a8 i almost want to play king e4
there by the way but
h5 we're waiting for this h5h4 by the
way
king c4 talk about unnecessary king
moves but she's protecting the pawn on
b4
and and you can tell lars wants to play
this position he doesn't want to drop
yeah but i think he's worse and i see
the evaluation part says as much
check okay and
rook b5 c7
all ideas so winning the b pawns losing
the c
pawns but now the d4 pawn stays and look
at the king look at that king
oh here it comes king e4 king f3
oh no this is a nightmare king i
actually have no idea who's better here
yeah i think i'd rather be black it just
seems trickier for white to deal with
this
king d1 oh bishop b4 was a mistake rook
a6 to cement the pawn on the dark score
was better
that's a great point yeah now the light
square pawn is is safe
rook b3 is the idea of a king e4 is fine
oh look at that clever move shutting the
rook off so you can win the pawn on a6
and king's oh knight c1 to b3 oh
king c2 can't be right no that way he
should be fixed now he's lost
bishop takes d4 and king king of three
blonders the bishop don't play king f3
wait the knight's just trapped f6
then it's completely stuck there's no
and then e4 is going to win that when
the knight
is completely stuck so oh my gosh wait
it's the wrong h-pawn so if you could
somehow
yeah usually you have no way to do it
but you just had to get in there and
point out it was the wrong h-button
wrong color h you never know when that
will uh make its presence felt
so uh it seems like we are actually
getting a break
right midway through the time patrol the
players get to
take a step back think about what's
happened and i think alina is going to
be happy because she has won
two more games to take a four game lead
so mon before we go on break
any sort of thoughts on what lars can do
to right the ship here
yeah can we talk about uh that for a sec
like hang on isn't
alina undefeated lars has to um go back
and really recalibrate in this uh three
minute portion so
i'm really excited when we come back to
see if he's gonna change anything
because it's just not working at all for
him right now robert
it really isn't even when he's up on
time things still are going to lead his
way she's kind of outplaying him so
all credit to her we will be back
shortly for more three minute plus one
second action from this i'm not a gm
specialist championship match
brought to you by chess.com
and we returned alina kashminskaya has
opened up a
four game lead over lars oscar hogg
amman
it's really tough sledding out there for
lars and
during the break we're kind of joking
around but how does he right the ship
how does he correct the mistakes he's
been making
does he need to play a different opening
which he seems to be doing every game or
what i don't know well the
some of the openings in particular that
i felt have not been going his way
especially the the new french line i
think he needs to examine that
uh because the the line that elena is
now going for
where getting these double pawns and
playing b6
i think it's really working out for her
so i would stay away from that line
um going into the rest of this
three-minute portion and especially
in the bullet it's gonna be more
pronounced if you really don't have a
clue what to do
so i would stay away from that i think
that the dutch is still very viable
he's been going for that but as i say
that he decides to switch that up and is
it going to be a grenfell
king's indian it looks like he's going
for kings indian
as he comes out of the break with again
something brand new
zero surprise that he's going for an
aggressive opening and the king's indian
if you look at it from this point of
view the bishop on g7 is stuck behind
some pawns
but it gives you chances to open up the
board later and this g4 line
is one that says f5 good luck making
that work because i'll take with my g
pawn and then my rook will come to g1
and your bishop on g7 will
be pinned to the king so this is just a
way to clamp down the position
i think very smart choice by elena and
uh i mean i might need some brushing up
on my theory here but knight b6 looks
like
a uh extremely peculiar move especially
because often times when you play this
the idea is hey you make white play b3
sometimes
that weakens the diagonal it's not what
you want to play but white was going to
go knight e2 knight g3
no matter what and that b6 just i mean
it looks really misplaced to me
it is very misplaced and black's best
move is pawn e5 back to e6 right you
need to open up this position
it opens up your bishop but also allows
you to start chiseling towards the
center
knight c5 good for you it attacks
nothing h4 says
i'm going to play h5 i'm going to play
bishop h6
i'm going to trade darts for bishops and
i'm just going to checkmate you
on the king side i have no idea what
lars is playing here because
there's there's not even a b5 in the
position a4 threatens nothing
f5 is just non-existent because white's
just going to take everything
and you can't give up your light squares
like that
so it's just like oh this is so bad
robert no
yeah it hurts to kind of look at here
but is the idea to go king f7
and run the king somehow is is there a
way to
king f7 rook h8 bring your other rook
over and then
run but the problem is there's also a
timely bishop takes c5
to then play d6 six six oh
and that bishop robert is not playing
chess for the rest of this game you mark
no no and then you can take on c5 and
play d6 and just open up the center
because
you're playing a piece down is black
your bishop is caught uh in the corner
and i would probably go for something
like that it's not
necessary and that's why alina is not
doing that
but i mean what does black do here it's
it's so bad because
i think what she's going to go for is
the more maybe traditional approach b3
a3 king b2 b4 maybe bring this knight to
e3
bring a knight to f5 and she's just
going to take her time
and she knows this is an absolutely
crushing position
yes one of these positions and we often
suggest it's the good thing to do is
what is your opponent's plan if they had
a couple free moves not just take all
the pieces but what actual plan
that isn't just relying on an opponent's
mistake and black does not have any
plans here
because your pieces are all stuck the e4
and g4 pawns
mean that f5 is impossible and if f5 is
impossible
your pieces over there that are just
lumped together on the king side doing
absolutely nothing
so if i'm going to talk about a plan
knight g6
knight h4 queen takes h6
okay trying to snag that pawn and just
go back and at least free
your yourself over here and a4 played
because b4 c5 is so crushing
that he says look i know i might lose
this pawn at some point it's quite
possible like bishop c5
bishop c2 queen d1 but i'd rather play
a4 get that in follow up with b6 and you
know
just just see what happens and another
thematic idea for white is to think
about knight to b5 and say you can take
my knight over there but once i take
with the c
pawn my rook is happy my rook can go to
c4 the a4 pawn is the target here and
while she goes for the exact thing you
were talking about queen back to d1
can you play queen e8 and yeah defend
there i was thinking about queen eight
i guess here you sort of have to decide
are you going to go knight h4 and focus
on liberating your bishop which is what
has happened
or are you going to go queen eight and
focus on trying to keep the queen's side
closed
i guess one of the major issues that if
queenie
was played the knight f5 happens and
your bishop is just frozen the bishop on
d7 you can take on f5 but then you'll
lose a4 eventually so
there was no choice you were losing this
a4 pawn and i like this
all things considered just i'm going to
try to win h6 so
yeah i would take on c5 i think and then
take on a4 and just i don't care about
the h pawn
but she's too strong knight f5 she's too
strong
just too strong she takes
and remember if pawn takes uh from the g
file
there is definitely a world where you
know there's like a sack on g5 to meet
the the black king
sacks on g5 second h4
the king is bottled up over there right
she sticks with the e pawn so she wants
to take on c5
and then put her knight on e4 at some
point exactly
that's just that's just a beautiful
positional way to play whereas you and i
were both like
let's go for checkmate why not where's
the maid
so if you move the knight knight takes
f3 becomes a possibility for black
because the bishop and a4 need defense
that's why
she wisely retreats her bishop and look
at this knight g2 i like that move
yeah so i mean say what you want but i
think
that lars's position has actually
improved
and um i don't believe what 92 is there
maybe even to go to d4 rather than take
the rook right that's what i was
actually looking at
yeah this is not so bad he gets h6 and
rook
slides over i mean he's holding
especially when
time travel ensues i mean there's no
knockout and that's the big problem
is once you play h6 it looks horrible
that bishop one g7 is a pawn
but it's a good pawn you're protecting
this is what dania says often and is an
expression
bad bishops defend good pawns and that
pawn h6 will save your king
the pawn in f6 keeps everything together
e5 and g5 so
it isn't that horrible yeah
at the right moment bishop f8 maybe h5
and rook h7 i like h5 rook h7 slide the
queen over and bishop d6 and you
you complete your building blocks over
here but i really think h5
just got to go for something like that
maybe rook h7 to preface it oh king h8 i
don't like
putting your king to make h5 more
difficult i'm not a fan of him
okay knight takes d5 so that is probably
what kha was played
yeah there are no pins there's no queen
b3 pin
can we make use of it at least uh the
king h8 move and go knight d5 what's
wrong with that
i think that elena will say you know
what i'll take it and open the board up
your bishop one f8 still stinks so look
at this she trades rooks off
and says hey how's that bishop feel it's
it's not an h8 anymore but it's not that
much better on f8
right i think you take and go h5 yeah
take this and go h5 like i think you
just
need to wait knight takes off six knight
f6
that's queen a4 a queen b3 as a response
that's an
important pawn but this is also good for
kf7 though
oh wait so you can't go queen in because
queen a4
check yep yep there's going to be queen
c6 as well
lurking in the position king g7 once
that happens
anything goes here queen b5 is how black
gets involved oh look at that
is knight g3 knight h5 coming does that
just i like queen b3
queen b3 looks good rook d1
so wow does rook d7 because in queenie
two check there's knight d2 so that
knights are excellent defenders
against queen checks very often king's
going to safety
rook takes c7 i say with no cop
what the queen's covering
oh my gosh oh my gosh now black is just
a head
and that's a queen exchange and rook f7
to follow or rook takes c6
yeah oh my gosh you know if you lost the
c
pawn there would be some chances for
white to hold because the h pawn's the
wrong bishop g7 and it's it's over
f6 rook f6 the rook is trapped the rook
is completely tracked
it went from black's bishop being
trapped on h8
robert by a pawn on h6 defended by the
rook on h1 to the rook on h1
being trapped by the bishop from h8 that
is
just terrible karma yeah that is
ridiculous
i mean that doesn't make any sense
whatsoever but you have to give
lars so much credit for fighting until
the very end this dude does not go down
without
clawing his way back into any sort of
counter play like he just
even the smallest bit of counter play he
latches on to and he flagged the lino
one game and he just won
that game where i mean frankly he didn't
really have any business taking that
full point
nope absolutely none that was incredible
that game was like plus four from the
opening without
any material imbalance robert that
that's incredible
not only was there no imbalance not a
single piece had been traded
oh my gosh and well look at this
game alina is up a pawn right now
because lars sacrificed one
and i'm not sure i'm buying it i feel
like this was a
questionable decision out of the opening
already for lars i see the
evil bar off the side says minus one but
sometimes minus one positions are very
difficult for black to play
i don't really have the sense that this
is that hard for black to
move forward in yeah i was gonna say you
sort of have to decide
um between moving this e pawn or not
like you can try to develop around it
but she says look i don't see any issue
with this sometimes the problem with
this is bishop d5
check and taking on e6 but
in this position there's always queen a5
picking up that bishop
potentially yeah and there's gonna be a
check but i think you can just block it
and then uh here you go queen a5 check
and there's no knight c3 which there
usually is
in positions with where you have this
tact such a good point that the knight
is not on the board to help you out here
but bishop c4 so
if you take on d5 queen takes d5 stares
in both directions at f7 and the b7 pawn
and e4 as well so in three directions
that's not good so taking is not going
to be played
probably oh queen f6 i was in queen b6
but queen f6 is way stronger
hitting b2 hitting f4 protecting e6
and he says i do not care
about b2 but yeah see overlooking b5
yes it did the bishop's trapped bishops
just tried you take
on e6 it's actually is it just pawn
takes that yes it looks weird but
take away that d5 square yep and i was
going to
recommend e5 first from black to then go
b5 because that way your
king wouldn't look less safe but this
works you're just winning a piece
and i suppose i don't think lars can
believe it look at his face right now
he's just kind of like um
is this really yes it's really trapped
right now
and he was the one going for tricks and
yet
he gets tricked because that bishop
stuck
and it's funny because he sacked that
pawn on e4 but it's that pawn
which is making the bishop trapped
it's a hero you know not the one that
maybe alina deserved but the one she
needed in this game it just
keeps that bishop locked in and this is
resignable
yeah it is it's getting we talk about
you know that plus four that elena had
in the last game
no material imbalance this is minus four
because there's gonna be a material
imbalance
and i'll say that this is some evidence
of
having good nerves for elena because in
the last game
she was really just cruising to a
victory she lost but then she bounces
back it's a
weird opening that you don't see every
day and yet she's handled it
perfectly finding moves like b5 and
this is just the position she's up a
piece and should not fear at all
absolutely knowing myself i would
probably play e3 here
because i'm scared i'm with you and it's
funny i'm on because you and i talked
about this before the show even started
we're just
you know hanging out and chatting like
sometimes we give too much respect to
our opponents where
we see a potential attack we're like no
no no i'm just gonna close things down
and
i think e3 was a great move but perhaps
it wasn't even necessary at that point
but i i like it i would have played the
same
safe and all the pieces are coming up
remember you can't castle without
blundering that bishop on d7
uh no doubt she's conscious of that rook
d8 is a move that comes to mind knight
e4 is obviously what lars is up to here
hitting the pawn sort of eyeing that
that d6 square but
um i think there's there's a lot of
reasons why that's not the end of the
world
yeah and knight d4 is saying i'm not
going to hang that bishop and
i'm going to close down the d file it
does make sense but white's next one
will be c3
the c5 pawn is hanging there's actually
some chance here
for lars and now they're heading towards
a minute and less and lars already below
a minute
but this is where mistakes happen right
except three checks at the rep by the
way
that's a nice one so c3 just knight
takes
f3 handles that because otherwise c3
looks so logical here
yeah that's important knight takes f3
and that's why
bishop takes was played but you have to
think here
you have to rook d8 the king is going to
get castled and that's the magic thing
as soon as the castling happens
you feel like alina is out of the water
although white now has
two pawns for the piece so it's not as
clear as it felt several moves ago the
bishop on d7 is hanging behind that the
bishop on e7 is hanging
and look at this move queen eight that
is the move that was needed to keep
everything tied together take on d6 move
your bishop away from d7 start trading
some pieces
you are up a minor piece for just a
couple pawns
oh she goes out there wow brave move
yeah absolutely knight b7 would make me
a bit concerned okay
yeah she just has full confidence look
at that queen went from e8 to b5
but not directly he went back to h5 and
then
to b4 that's clever so impressive to to
come
up with this because this is a better
version than giving up the bishop for
the night
but she comes up with this like it's you
know clockwork
i'm very impressed by it by that
maneuver
for sure and lars brings his queen back
to e3 bishop's seat
finally at long last we can start
training pieces and
now your extra piece makes his presence
felt
absolutely bishop to maybe a6 or b7
takes rook d3s who is in the position
i like that bishop b4 okay watch out for
some kind of knight f6 check though
right
not now yeah but some kind of knight f6
to shatter your pawn structure try to
get checks against the king
not too many pieces defending that black
king doesn't look like it's under attack
but it could be
yeah that's a good point rook c7 is
always going to fail to queen d1 check
although bishop d3 is knight f2
oh no this is getting funky oh no that's
a pin
and 15 seconds oh gosh
not again that's what she's thinking
right now because only a three game lead
seven seconds taking down robert oh my
gosh
and takes on d3 queen e6
that's what i was wondering do you throw
a queen e6 check here yes and there's
queen e4
right very important
not queenie hake is the queen of a4
covers but this check take on d3
oh my gosh lars is not his favorite
yeah but he's well on his way
looks very winning well queen if i want
a brave move what a good move i might
add
okay we see a repetition h4
where's the win here king h3 g3
maybe something like that okay queen d3
queen c2 queen d3 looks good with the
queen h1 check and take on e5 at some
point
black can likely take that knight and
try to hold that but
you get queen e2 maybe it's me oh it's
wait queen x5 queen h5 won the night
oh my god queen jack would have won the
night and she lost in time
she lost some time oh it hurts so bad
it hurts robert there were chances for
both sides to win that yeah of course
up a piece from the opening can we talk
about the resilience from lars i know
we were crediting the technique from
alina but he turned
an opening blunder of one entire piece
at the international master level into a
game that was not only competitive
but that he was even favorite to win so
this
is just incredible and if you're alina
now i was saying you know her nerves are
great but now your nerves might be
afraid and you're just angry
because you have been winning several
games in a row now
you're still up two so you should take
some solos in that fact
but i would be fuming at this point just
like how can i not
beat this guy i'm up a full piece and
the game before that the bishop was
trapped in h8 and yet that bishop
beat me so oh frustration
so many things that if there's one thing
that i truly believe
is in elena's favor right now it is you
know short-term
um memory loss like i don't think she is
thinking the way that you and i
are probably thinking that she's like
you know reflecting on the last game i
don't know like you're saying she might
be rattled
i don't think she's that kind of player
and you know that's just to her credit
if she can
always focus on the next game but you
just have to feel at some point
everybody is uh is susceptible to that
for sure and she actually has another
very good position
i'll say that much because wait the pawn
d4
you take that then d5 the position opens
up
which way is your king going neither
side is safe so lars
knight 65 right three pawn f
you know f6 i was trying to go f6 and e5
but somehow lars figured this out
he said i will lose a pawn but then d4
is hanging at the end that's actually
not that bad
yeah what clever guy very clever
lars is you know he's he's uh always
combing his hair back
as if he's about to put it in like a top
knot or something but it's like just
short enough that it's not possible but
it's long enough that he
constantly has to comb it so very
relatable things robert
as we get into the world of you know
hair and grooming and all that
and elena is locked in right now i mean
you look at her
she it's what happens to all of us when
we're playing on camera at first we
think okay this is the position i'm
going to be in the entire time
and then you start slipping you start
slipping and you're like next thing you
know your forehead's right against the
camera because you're staring
so intently at the computer screen and
wait a second
couldn't she have moved her bishop out
of the way first and then
uncorked a discovered attack with a rook
on d1 and that queen on d6
definitely yes i think there would have
had to have been like
some sort of queen e5 move or
something like that because i agree if
the bishop moved there was just knight
b6 check
i still like the position for white
i would play f4 here and then try to
play e5 i know it cost me
my f5 pawn but i don't really care about
that one so i would i think i'd play f4
e5 for white
yep the the worry here is that
if there's no immediate crush for white
i think black is just
better with the with the bishops
especially in an end game so i like that
four movie it you know pushes the tempo
yeah and gtx 5 is a very difficult move
to play knowing that e5 is coming and it
ruins your pawn structure as black but
e5 is happening whether you like it or
not and so you just have to accept that
fact
and it's played so the question is now
where do you put that queen queen e6 is
the greedy way to play try to hang on to
that pawn but knight g3 says no that's
not happening
this starting to look quite nice again
for white
uh so i'm trying to think long term here
isn't this knight just
better than the bishop for now but the
pawn on f4 perhaps could be a target
later or in the fact that bishop b6
covers g1
well not anymore but that could have
been useful if
black ever was able to seize control
with rook g8
i don't know a3 like that move just
taking the time out
um because look what happened queen c8
brook takes d7
it's almost like you got a free a3 move
in there and that's so
so useful i agree with you there and
that just make sure that the king won't
fall victim to some kind of background
checkmate
but i still don't know how white
proceeds from here
and i'm looking at that h7 pawn and
thinking well is the rook on egg kind of
tied down because if it moves then my
queen will open up an attack over there
but i don't see a useful knight move
right now knight d6 of course
comes to mind but maybe then that allows
the queen to go into g4 or something
like well speaking of queen g4
yeah it's possible now hitting the
knight hitting the pawn
rook g8 knight e4 and h6 but
knight c5 there knight c5 was excellent
she was focused on that f6 square but
knight c5 going queen b3 threading
checkmates throwing knight d7
check all that stuff wow i'm with you
there is it time for i was going to say
a6 wait no
97 knight d7 you can't go king b7
because knight c5
b5 was a blunder yeah and he knows he's
blundered
yeah that was a that was a big slip i
mean bishop d8 literally forced here but
there is going to be
some sort of check made on the board
knight b6 pawn takes queen d8 rook d7
and
i think you see that one as well but she
did not
and i see the evaluation bug go down
because queen f5 check
and then rook d3 the only way to survive
oh my goodness knight b6 was like just
screaming
knight f6 is actually a major blunder
here if he finds queen f5
not played and elena remains in control
yes because the bishop is still stuck
back there the
black king is open and the h-pawn is now
a passer yeah queen f5 and rook d3
is tough tough to spot very and
you know i really i always admit this i
quickly
looked over i saw that the evaluation
bar shrunk and what in the world could
it possibly how could this be equal
you need some kind of counter so i
thought queen of five checked but like
that didn't do anything
could be some wild move queen b3 hits
the rook as well with rook g2
yeah he does go for rook a3 this is
very interesting yeah you would love to
move your queen out the way and get a
new queen but
queen a2 check is happening this is
scary for alina
yeah this has really been been blundered
it's quite possible white loses this
game as well
look at the evaluation bar it just oh
queen f5 oh quinn
i mean queen f5 is so so nasty with rook
a1 and he
he knows he's got the win here okay one
of those queen takes f4
it all looks good for black yes and this
is going to be the
third game in a row where lars oscar
hogg
looked like he was dead lost he had
nothing going for him
but he fights to the very end and he is
going to take this game
unbelievable stuff frankly i think you
just take that rook
let the queen happen regroup and then uh
you know start brook f1 rook d3 in the
checks from there
yeah rook f one king two e4
queenie two i mean there has to be a i
think you just ladder
just ladder the whole way across the
board yeah queen g2 rugged one
just yeah there's speaking a lot meeting
two and
wow
and we still with time for one more game
and i feel like that is not good news
for alina because
she probably could use a break right
about now
losing three straight games and lars
once again goes for some kind of
offbeat opening here oh and you know
what this one is
this is this the ortho snap or something
that's what it says i
i didn't know what it was called but i
see french defense steiner
ortho schnapp gambit and i'm like does
that mean i'm gonna about to get my
teeth fixed and this is what's happening
here yes
this this is the one that i i mean i
think
uh jonathan schrantz uh had the video
on this first i know that eric rosen has
some videos
on this but i can't remember who did it
first anyways both of those guys love
making videos on super creative openings
and the idea is exactly this
you just play knight f3 castle knight c3
and look at the insane
amount of development and compensation
it's just a very fun way to play so i'm
really excited we're seeing this in the
match
yeah you know it rivals only the drum
gambit in terms of
it just just uniqueness and just it's
allure so
here black is up two pawns but the king
is in the center
f7 is under attack how does black
castle you're not going to be able to
castle are you no
basically the the answer is no uh i
think that
after d3 taking it already invites a
tough position i think i think
lars is extremely happy with what he's
got he's almost pre-moving
rookie one if not for d2 or something
but
this looks incredibly good for white and
i think rookie won
king f8 knight c3 or or bishop g5 i mean
he is doing very well here yeah the the
really bad news for
elena is that she's cleared out the
pieces in between her king and a rook on
the king side but now she's had to move
her king
and the queen side remains
underdeveloped so
bishop takes f6 may seem too scary to
allow
but i think you just have to and then
your king gets the g7 square to run
so i i think all things considered
knight c6 was a good choice
and if i'm lars i want to just play like
knight c3
rook a d1 get all my pieces in but
knight a5 is currently an idea
for lena and yeah i think knight a5 he's
i guess gonna meet it with queen takes
d3
yeah i guess yeah whatever you know i'm
getting one pawn back and i still have
the initiative
there might be queen c3 and bishop f6
though oh
i thought he was throwing in bishop f6
he could have
but he said that let's just do this i
like that idea though bishop takes f6
for sure
because now there's going to be a great
tactic c6
knight d6 queen he said bishop e7 check
that is
beauty so sick and i think i think that
she was planning
on playing c6 and now has to rethink
things because
she maybe noticed this at the last
second the pin there and the fork there
yeah it's one of those situations where
you want to think what changes with
every single move well in that case
the d6 square wasn't covered the queen
was loose so you just need to remove the
piece
in between the queens that were staring
each other down now that you played f6
and c6 the e6 square is weaker that's
where white would like to take advantage
of but you have a bishop on c8 so
i feel like alina is a couple moves away
from
finishing her development coordinating
her pieces and i'm not
trying to claim she has an advantage
necessarily but king f7
comes to mind right now and doesn't look
as bad
yeah i'm i'm looking at bishop g3 to get
rid of that bishop and threaten 95.
i like that keep in mind if you move the
rook i know people have not been taking
h7 pawns this match robert but queen
takes h7
95 check 90 95 game over we mentioned
that tactic
and now it's happened without sacrifice
as necessary that's going to be game
over
and that's going to be the end of the
portion and look at the difference it
was like
3-0 like from alina
4-0 i think before the break and all of
a sudden it's come back and look at this
it's a tied match what the heck is going
on robert
yeah she was up four games and now lars
has given me some like joel kinnaman
vibes because he's just killing it right
now and
she just can't handle it i mean every
single game with the exception of this
last one she's had an
advantage and yet he's come back in one
so i'm going to ask you before we go to
break
what can alina do to correct what's
happening here because
she's losing her lead yeah i'm trying to
think
what exactly lars did differently um
from the break that has caused him to
get all these wins but honestly it's
just been
uh tenacity like he hasn't gotten the
best position so this game was an
outlier i think this was a fantastic
game but
in general he hasn't gotten the best
positions but he's so tenacious he stays
in there even wondering a full piece
in the opening i think that his key
right now is play fast
take those slightly worse positions and
then you know stay in the game and his
time scrambling
we got to give him some credit there so
alina great chess
um and just slows down at the end we'll
have to see if if she can
right the ship in bullet because we know
that she is incredibly strong
in the bullet portion despite being slow
in earlier formats
for sure and one player who has
accomplished a lot despite being the
underdog was teddy coleman in the last
year's edition so we'll see if alina
can just you know make sure that her
nerves don't get the best of her we'll
be right back shortly and we'll come
back to the bullet portion of this i'm
not gm speed chest championship match
we just like to remind everybody that
season six of arena kings is underway
it has already begun and the events are
on mondays and fridays
it's a lot of fun you can play against
people in your rating range and also
maybe have the chance to play
against the likes of hikar nakamura ali
raza fruja alexander kasenyuk and the
one and only prophet
danya naraditsky aman and i you know
both enjoy those tournaments maybe you
can
beat up on us as well but i'm on here
we're focused on nothing
except for the one plus one the bullet
portion of this match
it is all tied up the momentum has
certainly swung
lars oscar hogg's way elena kashlinskaya
what in the world can she do as she's
the underdog and
she must be frustrated after those last
four games
yeah i guess the break was kind of well
timed before
it got really out of hand because it's
very easy to lose
one two three four and especially going
into bullet when you're on a losing
streak it can
really be like 10 games in a row just
like that so i think a break before the
bullet is important
uh she can look at these tricky openings
that lars has been playing and say look
i don't want to go into these in bullet
imagine
defending this position robert in a
bullet game that would just be insanity
you can't be going into those
let's see if she's changed things up and
is really
uh basically conscious about what
opening she's going for and lars
we can see he's played bullet before
because look at what he's doing
he looks like me out there because this
is what i play no matter what
uh i play the hippo style you get your
bishop staring at the center the knights
in the center of the board here
but look at alina she's keeping pace and
that is essential
she has a better position and she's
doing well on the clock so c5 d5 i think
e5 is going to be played
and will we see that bishop end up
trapped by its own pawns again
it looks like it that dark sword bishop
not very happy yeah this is a
great game so the thing is a lot of
times a player
let's say such as elena who generally
gets low on time
what you'll see is that in a bullet game
they just go in with a mindset hey
we can't take time in this format not
acceptable and all of a sudden
they start to trust their instincts and
you realize as you're watching them wait
she has really good instincts she should
do this more often
she's actually looking really
comfortable in this bullet portion which
is why i was saying
keep that in mind going into it so right
here we see a great position for elena
but
typical fashion lars is messing things
up yeah he is he's just mixing it up
here he opens up the b-file he
sacrifices a pawn
queen takes b5 the queen come to c6
that's important as if the d-file is
open
opens up the d6 pawn is under attack but
i think that lars should be
very happy at this point and he goes
queen a7
there's a look at taking d6 i would say
oh that's a really nice tactical shot so
that would give her a quick
attack on black's king and i think c4
here why not c4
c3 even like it
like it takes and you know playing rook
a8 rook b8 you can't
can't say that's going to be too bad as
well
bishop c1 rook a8 will be it as you said
and then
okay rook b3 was i like that move that's
and knight a5 there's even b4 to
consider
oh good eye by you there and actually
the king can go to c2
and it's not 100 safe but it's not
getting checkmated
yeah it's pretty reasonable actually and
by the way alina is up on the clock you
don't take on d5 because queen
c4 would have pinned the knight instead
we well how does he get that pawn back
he wants this and queen a2 checked okay
kingston then queen c2 though yeah alina
is doing great here
you have to trade queens because after
queen before rook b1 the knight of b6 is
under attack
but then queen c4 and then take the
knight yeah i think i think queen f1 was
let's say overestimated because
everything is protected yeah he's got to
take that pawn but this can't work out
no she can just play king e1 the knight
e4 is very powerful
it blocks that queen's accent diagonal
you can play f3 if you need to and queen
b3 trying to she sees queen b3 that's so
so important have to trade d5 gonna be
attempted here but knight c3
and there we go that's the rook you see
him laugh
and then he laughed and then looked
upset i don't even know how he's feeling
right now
yeah it's hard to say now with the white
pieces
he is opening with e4 he's opening with
e4
he's just that just a happy chap there
on the cam um
do you think he's going to be repeating
that opening with black or is that an
experiment you know for game one of
bullet
and and you might adjust it going
forward well it seems like he's been
watching me stream and
that's a big mistake because i always
say there's a disclaimer
do as i say not as i do and that opening
is bad i think he should not go back to
it but i wouldn't be surprised if he
does
just because he's used to that and
especially for players who
play a lot of hyper bullet you're just
used to going but there's increment here
it's not pure bullet alina is playing
very quickly in this game as well
but i like oh wait i liked let me take
it back i liked lars's position until he
hung the d4 pawn
yeah there's got to be f6 now it's the
only move followed by queen h4
something like that like to just make
things a little bit spicy
right but if the queen's where there's
knight f5 oh it's a 93 oh my gosh
what robert you're leading them astray
my bad
my bad um maybe this isn't the end of
the world of bishop
bishop g5 now it is the uh that's the
end of the world yeah yeah
okay i'm just gonna stop talking yeah so
every
everything you've said so far
unfortunately has been
heated advice but um no all jokes aside
this was
it you know this is bullet totally
different game robert that f6 move
it might not work in you know the time
controls we've seen before but whoa rook
e4
right back in the game is alina and
that's a large type of situation you're
down a piece but you still
keep your head on wait that's it
yeah knight takes f5 the f6 pawn is what
you want to get out if you could take
that the king is stuck on h8
checkmate but b4
i don't think knight h6 was the right
move just bishop d4 keep the pressure
but taygo knight takes up sick oh then c
takes b2 what a nice take b2
and wow i think that's what was
overlooked by lars because it looked
like you're getting two rooks for a
queen
the king on aj didn't look very safe but
look at this you don't even have rook b6
which would have pinned the knight
because the a7 pawn the a7 pawn is the
hero
i like rook b7 uh oh he's trying to pin
it but it's just
not working hang on what's what's the
move here queen seat shoe
i guess whoa i don't like giving him
that pawn
no this this one's not this hang on okay
black can't win this game now
oh knight g3 yeah but even if you lose a
rook for the night it's still going to
be drunk
that's true knight f2 you can play wait
wait knight of two there might be some
kind of smothered mate almost like
yep queen b6 coming soon be careful uh
oh rook g3
super careful although okay and rookie
three
where's the king goes h8 it's working
fake me wait how do you get out of this
it's over you don't what's game over
world
this game has been both players for the
taking
and now finally lars should just pick
off that night
white wins this game for sure or
you know this game goes ages and ages
and ages
so it seems like it should just be a win
for white you can just slowly build up
rook f3 because you can trade two rooks
for the queen
and it should be winning not a fan of g3
though there are some positions where
you give up the
queen for the two rooks and still make a
draw because of it depending on where
the pawns are
so king of chicks this looks scary there
could be some stalemates
wait queen sack somewhere watch out for
three stage four queen explorer
greece whatever give your queen away
yeah yeah there it is
and then queen two queen h2
yeah exactly well actually she can waste
some time
if she wants i don't know if that's part
of the plan
oh my gosh yeah this is at least a draw
now
for sure yes and she can let
lara try to play on for win and then you
know there could be something
she can play queen g2 anytime she wants
and it's
wrong and this is why you always need to
be careful
about how many squares your opponent's
king has because lars was
trying to checkmate the king and it
would have been checked me if he could
land a check but it wasn't lena's turn
she said let me give my way my queen no
more moves for me
and it's actually kind of funny that
alina played that whole game
to the end without giving up the queen
for nothing you know what i mean like
the chess player in me the the
beautician in me
has to give up my entire queen at the
end to make the draw but she's just
checking as if it doesn't exist
right whereas we know that she saw it
for sure for sure
and well she gets the white pieces again
lars spent some time in the opening
which is strange honestly in a second
move he spent a lot of time so
that's not good for bullet chest you do
get the increment he can bounce back
from that
but it's one of these positions where
alina proved like she
knows what she's doing and i think she
you know she just feels comfortable the
opening in this match
whoa do not like c5 at all
yeah not a fan contrarily i love the
apon push
because the knight gets into b5 long
term hits the a7 pawn it's just
something you always have to worry about
right and the only downside could be is
if the queens and the rooks get traded
then your a6 pawn can be picked off
but you're not going to trade all these
pieces there's too much left on the
board and
the bishops stare down black doesn't
really want to take and allow the queen
into f5
so it's going to continue i like the
idea of getting rid of that bishop which
makes knight b5 just sting
that little bit more um in general
right and take it with the pawn on d4
that's interesting i wasn't expecting
that
why do you oh because if she took the
knight then she would have double her
pawns in the g
file i also don't mind you know taking
those squares i agree it's not what i
would first think of but
now that it's happened i don't think
it's the worst and now it looks like a
french defense
right and here comes the queen to g6 and
watch out for the king safety and
knight b5 so white is playing on both
sides of the board knight b5
may just win material at any moment to
get the c7 square
and queen g6 of course is natural
so there's knight f5 ideas
just sort of looming mm-hmm there's
rook c1 rook c2 now the rook can go
to g3 if the knight goes out the way uh
queen d3 i was gonna say hang on almost
lost a knight there
right so she's repeating i'm he doesn't
want him he never wants to repeat
yeah just just no he is the type of
player
it seems that he's playing for a win
every single game without fail
there's still nothing i see like 92
knight f4 to try to bring more pieces
but i don't see
any threat lars is just jumping around
the board taking the pawns
he's doing a good job and knight f4
knight g6 that's
an idea for sure yeah and how to follow
well i
didn't like knight e5 i like sitting
tonight on g6 and keeping it there
knight b5 into d6 may as well you know
interesting that maybe if it was not
played it also threatened the a7 pawn
now knight b5 for sure broke c2 ooh
quick counter shot great find there yeah
that's a problem
rook takes b2 yeah
and a7 rook a2 so knight d6 was played
and two pawns down isalina
she does have good chances just because
it feels like the king on h7 isn't
completely safe but knight takes e5
that is just that's beautiful yeah
nicely done and look at all these white
pieces on the last rank careful for rook
check and knight f3 mate there it is
double check which is me
knight g4 knight of three good find by
you great find by
lars really well done by him in that
game and now it's a tied match once more
yeah and this is so exciting i i don't
think that i've had the pleasure of
uh commentating match yet that we knew
going into the bullet and has been
proven in the bullet format
to be neck and neck going to the finish
this might be decided robert by like a
single game with time expiring
yeah we still do have just under 14
minutes left plenty of time for the
players
even if they drop a game here but you
don't want to
be down the scoreboard and right now
lina goes back to this french
lara says don't mind if i do i just was
crushing you before i blundered my
bishop one before
yeah and it's the same exact line and i
don't think he will play queen e1
anymore
yeah it's one of those things where your
move wasn't so good but it resulted in
something great so
unfortunately you have to switch it up
not then right
and rook c8 played makes sense still no
queen e1 because the d4 pawn is hanging
that sacrifice is possible with f6 at
any moment
but you have to be certain otherwise you
actually open up the board
for black's pieces and that will
backfire
yeah and you can't get bishop d2 or
anything like queen d3 maybe for bishop
d2 i feel like you want a complete
development but
maybe h3 i would almost just play
waiting he plays it again that's
hilarious
i just don't believe in it so let's
pause for a second knight f5 was not a
good move
knight five is also not necessary but
their knight is under attack so look at
her
so many moves knight g4 okay
understandable so he wants to just play
pawn takes pawn it looks like
so how about now rook g8 you just take
pawn takes pawn
wait so pawn takes pawn and knight g5 oh
gosh
that was the whole plan knight g5 is
killer
it's too much to work out in a bullet
game oh my goodness he's gonna play
queenie one non-stop robert
it's working it is working it's working
like a charm but it shouldn't work
and i feel convinced you know because
the threat was pawn takes f6
maybe some kind of like rook c4 move
i've been thinking about this pinning
that knight
so that you can take back on f6
something like that it just doesn't feel
like it should be enough for white
you're only attacking with a couple
pieces so
if alina is able to figure that out then
she will turn this to her advantage but
right now this is lars the game
i think you can yeah i was going to say
knight g5 um
is just waiting to happen knight g5
takes and like rook takes f7
also looks pretty good
yeah rook f7 is a threat and queen takes
g8 oh
queen take g a new queen that hurts
that really hurts yeah and f7 is hanging
as well so this will probably be resigns
there it is and lars he's making these
attacks work robert he's
he's getting you know he's mixing things
up he's getting spicy positions that
objectively as soon as he plays queen e1
you see that eval bar just
what is this i think it was a mouse slip
i think he wanted f5 he's like
okay okay it makes sense yeah now he
plays f5
because you don't win a game take the
lead and then do this you
are either down four points and are just
tilted or you're up a ton and do
whatever that was definitely a mouse
lift
yeah it's not that bad it's not that bad
now because the knight gets to f5 and
it's actually like
very okay wow i wish i could
make mouse slips like that and not have
to pay any sort of price
yeah yeah what the what the heck just
happened i don't know how that worked
out but
i saw the the webcam when lars played f6
and he gave the face like ah that was a
mouse flip so
i think it was but he can't be
complaining here
although where's his king going because
bishop d3 the g6 pawn is weak
so he plays 97 he's gonna try to castle
queenside that takes way too much time
though i feel like
yeah he's swinging bishop c6 queen d7
and well he's actually or queen d6 he's
actually going to get it
but then c5 before b take c4 take c4
okay yeah oh wait ticking c4 would be
good
yep look at this though the rook on h2
will swing over to the queen side and
help with the attack
uh-oh oh no no
not again not again
take me eyes but not me bishop no that
bishop on eight is just
oh gosh is he gonna win another game
with a
basket piece that doesn't exist i he he
could because a5
if you take on passant you lose the c6
pawn and well
if you don't take no no she's not taking
that she's not taking that
yeah oh my gosh
i mean black's not even worse anymore is
black
look better what oh gosh
okay then g fun
e3 hello gosh oh no
oh my goodness maybe knight c3 to e4
he's giving peace odds yeah
which gives her a chance actually as
this game continues
whoa no that pawn's important oh my
goodness
that pawn's real important oh oh queen
e5
queen e5 hurts rick f8 queen
actually doesn't have a mating threat
yet though but queen f5 check picks up
the bishop but queen a1 just king z2
immediately i i would resign asap
doesn't even
cover how quickly i resign you needed
six queen g6 and brook g8
i'm not mistaken to mom wouldn't you
resign too just you need to get the next
game going
uh i probably wouldn't resign this
because i would rationalize
that materials even because there's a
bit of money
i see the evaluation bar it's not that
bad for white
how is this possible this is what i
wanted if you put the rook on g8 and
then you just
bring the knight in bring the knight oh
my gosh if you can bring that knight
over there
like 1997. he's exactly 97 is winning
so a 96 knight c2 knight before 96.
oh my god he's winning for white oh no
bishop d4
no but then just take the pawn and then
you have don't judge the bishop
don't take the bishop don't take the
mission
don't take it she's not taking it that's
beautiful
oh my gosh she's not taking the bishop
and she didn't resign and it's paying
off
wait you should yeah she's not taking
anything she's winning
oh my goodness oh my what
the hell is going on here yeah what is
happening
wait black's getting out of this wait no
down the road
oh my gosh she hung the rook
wait a minute we've seen this before she
literally lost a rook to the bishop that
was trapped
that's the second time this match that
the trapped bishop
has somehow come out of nowhere robert
had taken her brook
that is what the hell that's just
devastating
and we have this line that i don't
understand again
i can't breathe i'm seriously impaired
god
oh my gosh this hurts okay let's talk
about one thing
positive in the alina camp she looked at
this line a thousand percent
yes she's playing a very good i would
say close to refutation
queen e7 queen before check and she is
so ready for this i can tell that she
looked at this
after the break from the three minutes
yeah and now she's up
a pawn and there's no attack and it's
white's king that's being attacked
bishop f5 will just win next move and
the knight before
yeah yeah uh okay this is looking
fantastic
so how to win this game it feels like
there's a win in like two moves
yeah a4 looks quite good as well
um
bars and pieces on in the corner robert
bishop's knights it doesn't matter with
him
yeah he's just i don't even know how to
explain it but
he's throwing those pieces left and
right and
take and rook d4 oh c6 b5 the bishop is
trapped now b5 rook takes d3
and then rook d8 something like that i
feel like
this is a reasonable move but maybe is
there g4 no not quite
no king c1 that's a good move just
avoiding the pin
yep and now f3
f3 looks good you can't take on c5
because your knight gets pinned so
unless i don't think you can although
maybe you can
c5 and like i guess there's back rank
issues though
yeah now although blacks have a pawn
i think you'd agree knight c6 yeah you
got to be so careful here tactics rook
takes d5 oh 97 check rook deep oh my god
87 checked first oh it had to be rook c8
there
yeah no alina she needs to resign now
she needs to resign
now i agree because you're going to be
down three
points you need to start the final game
before
the clock hits zero so if you win two
games here she will have a chance to
come back
so of course has to be a very very quick
win here
from uh from alina like not winning that
game is so bad
uh for the match because that was that
was the the position that was like
she she did her homework she came
prepared for that same line that lara's
brought to
the table and not winning that game has
got to hurt her mental she
she has to win like a very quick game
right now yeah and lars goes on these
streaks remember he was down four points
then he won four in a row
then he lost an early bullet game and
now he's won
three or four in a row even like losing
track of the numbers but yeah now his
position he has a monster center with
these three pawns here and
now they're going forward so the way
this can backfire
is if white can open up the board and
that's a good way bishop c4 check kind
of ideas
well actually knight 64 queen d5 check
is possible as well but the point is
that the king on j8 isn't actually that
safe over there mm-hmm
just take that and some sort of
shack or maybe an id4 to e4
i love knight dd4 protects the e3 pawn
hits the g4 knight hits the d6 bishop
this literally hits everything in the
position and she didn't
oh oh queen takes g2 there's issue e6
check
to throw in perhaps and then rook f1
kind of thing uh
yeah i'm not a wait queen g2 queen g2
rook f1
e4 d6 hangs but
white's king is in big trouble yeah
knight
b4 by the way tonight c2 or knight d3 is
also
pretty crushing queen f2 queen f2 game
over rook d8 or queen takes g1
ouch ouch that might be the dagger right
there
uh you know three minutes left in this
match more or less i think it's
pretty much impossible that alina makes
a comeback now robert
no and i mean what a comeback from lars
down four points looking like everything
is going alina's way
and then he just goes on a winning spree
and doesn't stop
because he went from minus four to plus
four that's an
eight point swing and
it's a weird match because if you told
me just by looking at the games that
somebody is winning this match
by four points i don't think i would
think it was lars
yeah yeah like it you you'd assume that
eventually all the good positions that
alina was getting all match
would would you know finally result in
it going in her direction and g5 is
going to be taken
no calculation needed and this rook e3
queen h6 this is over
this has got to be over yeah and now
it's just
you know adding insult to injury at this
point just
you're already wounded you've lost this
match that
was going your way and now your king is
blasted open on move
15. this is resignable basically
rook g3 check um knight takes e5 you can
just take that back first
yeah nothing to do here it's queen g5
check this is
one of those moments where okay this
match can end now this is
it feels like it's time i'm over this
yep
and time takes down but there's just no
resources here unfortunately g5
um she kind of forgot i guess that the
queen was on d2 um
often the queen is not on d2 it's on e2
but that's an easy sacrifice to make
rook g3
that's gonna be it yep might get one
more game here
yeah we do get one more so probably not
another game that alina wants to play
but there's still time left in the clock
and we have a budapest so that's
always fun and that has been a good
thing in this match we've seen a
different opening
most games and this is tricky white is
up a pawn
but black has quick play and now the e5
pawn is under attack but she seems to
know this queen d5 is
the principal move well it's not like
principle it's the good move but it's
hard to play
to bring your queen out into the center
like this
and uh d6 played i think usually they go
f6 there
but d6 looks a little bit worse uh to my
eyes white's just gonna finish
that development and uh kind of looks
looks super solid here actually for for
alina right and it's sort of
in a sense kind of like an orthoschnat
reversed where
it's an extra pawn for white
but the black is really going full steam
ahead trying to create some play but
you're not in time i don't think
no bishop d3 looks super strong and a3
even here
yeah just not dealing with knight b4 um
g5 is usually what black wants to throw
in but now i'm not sure it works because
you're actually in a pin
right and i will add that bishop a5 by
black was a really
clever move trying to get knight b4 hope
that you're not looking for it
but of course a3 was the easy response
and now
white's up a pawn you've castled you
should be able to take
advantage here but you also don't have
that much time and the match
is officially over after the scheme and
reposition
maybe not that bad for black because of
white's double isolated sea fonts
yeah knight e5 b6 and you can
you can sort of play around the the
extra pawn
that alina has which is pretty much the
whole point of this opening so it's
very very in line with what to expect
and it went from
tactical to incredibly positional yeah
i didn't think the game would take this
turn here but now c4 falls
and black must be thrilled about the
position uh the a3 pawn
hangs with a fork and let's just say
alina will be
not disappointed to get get out of this
match
yes when it rains this point it is just
absolutely pouring
yeah i mentioned that this is how bullet
can go sometimes robert you lose one
you lose two you might be a streak but
in bullet it can turn into ten games
just like that
so lars was an incredible streak in the
bullet portion and
that was just you know alone that's what
won him the match plain and simple
rubber
yeah he was able to fend off some
horrible positions and he fought tooth
and nail
that kind of defensive resource should
be praised we're gonna take a quick
break because when we return we'll be
joined by the players we'll get to hear
their thoughts
on what was an exhilarating matchup
between two very strong competitors
we shall be right back
and we return with the players uh alina
our apologies that the
match not go your way and
congratulations to you lars
and we'll start with you lars what
happened there how were you able to turn
it around you were down by
four points in the match what did you
tell yourself what did you change
yeah at some point it was looking really
grim but i i kind of had the same
idea or planned over so much which was
just that i was
go i was going to try to win every game
so the plan itself didn't
change but it was looking pretty hard at
some point there
because in like the last five minute
games on the
two first three games i
got crushed really i mean i i lost like
two drone and games as well
because i was trying to like press on
time but um
after that i kept winning bad positions
and then
like everything went my way like except
the openings like i was losing after
almost
like 15 moves every game but
it went really well after the openings
in the last games
yeah that's uh we thought maybe i was
gonna mention one of the openings that
you chose in particular
that worked really well the first time
you tried it which was the ortho schnapp
that you uh you brought out and uh
credit to alina because it looked like
she did you check that alina in the
break after the three minute because he
played it again in bullet
and it looked like you came with almost
a refutation
oh no i didn't check the opening i i was
happy with what i was
getting after the openings the problem
was not in this part of the game but
somehow i couldn't convert my winning
positions i mean
and of course congratulations to lars
for for fighting so hard and i mean
yeah i mean especially that game when i
was pissed up and i lost it on time i
mean that was
that was horrible from my site yeah and
elena at what point did you feel like
the match was slipping because you had
the four point lead and it seemed like
you were getting great positions and
what happens one time maybe you can
forget about it but was it the second
the third time when did you really feel
like things just
were falling apart uh i
i felt bad when i lost the fourth game
in a row because it reminded me
of the game against of the match against
john bartolome last year when i
lost six games in a row somehow i should
work on this stop losing click you know
stop at some point because i think in
the third game i lost i could
after rook takes you three i could just
go for a draw and i don't know where i
but i started to blunder everything
and uh yeah at that point i thought that
i'm in trouble but then in one plus one
uh
i i thought it was uh back in the game
but
uh again i started i started to blunder
at some point and i couldn't stop
that was a problem yeah that the
blunders obviously were
they're hard to avoid and and there are
plenty i mean lars i have to ask you
because it seemed like a theme
in this in this match uh you had a
bishop trapped on
a8 trapped on h8 i mean it's like you
were addicted to these
what do you have to say about that yeah
it's like something that usually
never happens and then i got it like
twice in this match
uh or yeah twice or three times um
and like the first time i i just
blundered it but the time when i got the
bishop on a8 it was kind of intentional
but it didn't
didn't really work out because i have no
idea how that position
was like when the rick was on g8 like
the end game after exchange queens
yeah robert and i were actually having a
a crazy time analyzing that and watching
it happen because believe it or not
alina played that to a point where it
was actually winning for white
at many many points in that end game and
and obviously just dropping the rook
uh was the difference but i think that
position was actually better for white
surprisingly
yeah yeah at the end i thought so too
brian like before i rendered like the a
pawn i
thought like i should like i have three
past ones
but and i have like the idea to take on
c6 to get another one
but yeah about that position was really
crazy like i'm a piece on
a couple of pawns up and it's still like
super hard for me in the end game
yeah well i know it's getting late for
you both but lars one last question you
will
face the winner of teddy coleman and
karissa yipp what do you feel like you
need to change
so that you can keep winning and moving
on in this tournament
uh probably the openings the openings
went very poorly
this much um
[Music]
and maybe i've blundered a bit too much
but i think mainly the openings so i
should just find something
that i'll play every game instead of
like switching between
opening lines that i don't know for sure
that makes sense
well lena again our apologies the match
can go your way but you have so many
fans out there who are rooting you on so
you
should hang your head high and uh you
know be very proud and we're happy that
you
participate in this event thank you
good luck and good luck for lars in the
in the following matches of course i'll
be waiting for you
well here you heard their thoughts lars
going forward maybe he needs to fix
something in the opening and maybe
stick to an opening that's interesting
and he will await the winner of
teddy coleman and carissa yip down in
the bottom right
hand side of the bracket so amman as you
look at the bracket
we still have a couple three first round
matchups to go
and i don't know i don't even know what
to think right now after
that fun match that was awesome and and
i said it right at the beginning
that maybe some people on uh
twitch aren't as familiar with the two
competitors today
but in my opinion we've had some crazy
ones danny versus lawrence we've had
levy rosman you know tons and tons of uh
fans
uh on twitch but i actually thought that
this was seriously the most entertaining
match that
um that we got to witness and commenting
on and people got to see
the personalities of the players as well
i think alina not only did she start
with a lot of fans as you mentioned but
probably collected a few more with uh
with an ever gracious
post-game interview there you know
wishing her uh
competitor good luck in the future
rounds and actually cheering for him to
win the whole thing so that she can say
yeah you know i just lost to the winner
second year in a row that would be the
case if lars is able to move on and win
this whole thing
and i just wanted to state that that
match score is very misleading
i mean it looks like a lopsided affair
it looks like lars was
just storming through and crushing the
match but no of course if you go back
through it
there are many moments that both players
wish they could take back and i really
just
was impressed i know i sound like
mayor's being a little bit harsh about
lars's play
but the ability to not lose these
completely losing positions that is a
talent in and of itself
and i don't say that lightly that is
something you see some of the best
players in the world do like even
like the players the very top sometimes
hikaru nakamura gets a horrible position
and i'm just like wait still still
fighting still fighting wait a second
he's turned this around and he's winning
the game so that
kind of skill is absolutely essential
in a several hours long match yep that's
a great point now the clock is
is part of the match and you know
there's always a best move to be found
no matter if if it's uh you know good
position few or a bad position so
full credit to lars and i think alina
realized that as well giving full credit
to him for being so resilient
and not being too frustrated like oh man
you played like trash you were losing
every game
we didn't see that attitude at all it
was it was more like wow that was
actually very impressive
defense by lars so if he gets some
better opening positions
that when he has those bad games he can
come back
the way that he did in this match but to
get them less often to give himself a
better chance i could definitely be
a front-runner for potentially the
finals in this tournament if you keep
that up
yeah especially if he plays the way he
did in those first two games of the
match and then
in the bullet portion i would say that
that was lars in
full force and the orthoschnapp game
can't forget about that success
that was his best one for sure
well on that note the match has come to
its conclusion we want to just remind
everybody that there will be so many
more fun events
upcoming arena kings is in full swing we
will
also have pogchamps 3 starting in
february
not all of the players are known yet
there still are a few names to be
announced
but just the players we have ensure that
it will be a great one
amman hey man i have so much fun
commentating these matches for you this
was the most fun i've had yet
yeah and we're getting lucky because uh
not only is it a good time anyway but
the matches that we've cut to commentate
have had evaluation bars that are
basically doing push-ups the entire time
i mean up down you name it the the
matches have been exciting
they have been very close even though
the final score never seems to reflect
that
someone always runs away with it at the
end but all the matches that we've
commented have been exciting
there's just enough high level play and
then just enough blunders that it's the
best of both worlds so
it's been a pleasure commentating
alongside you robert and of course we'll
be we'll be back for many more of these
for sure and i just want to say while
the players they showed their nerves of
steel in this match particularly lars
tata steel resumes tomorrow you will not
want to miss the world's absolute best
players taking on each other head to
head match-ups in classical time
controls dania naraditsky and fiona
stanley tony will have the call it's
going to be another good one so for now
keep enjoying chess enjoy the rest of
your days but don't forget to tune back
in
for that tournament once again tomorrow
see everybody
you